Oh, good googly Mowgli.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this episode of the podcast,
if you're looking for like a regular
podcast where people are going to talk
about interesting shit and bring
up topics that are fascinating and
intellectually stimulating, that shit
ain't happening today. This episode.
What are they saying? Are
they saying that? No. What
are they saying? The sing us.
Oh Shit. We're already live.
You late. Fucks sit down,
up. Sexy face. Have you been
back to the freezing place?
And so we grabbed that backpack.
You guys were broadcasting. Don't
have a, just a regular conversation.
This is actually a podcast. Yeah, it's
videotape. Videotape to we're live.
That's true. You don't want to be
videotaped. We can go incognito.
We can just put a logo on my face,
right?
We're a, this is like I was
saying before, you guys walked in.
This episode is not a regular podcast.
This is what we're calling,
we're calling them the fight
companion podcast. We did it, uh,
during the last few of see broadcasts
that a I wasn't a part of and we had a
great fucking time. So we decided
to do it again. Brendan Chavez here.
Hollow Brian.
Brian Cowan is here, edge it
bra is here, the original,
uh, and uh, we are watching a,
yeah, yeah, sure. I'll get you some,
some nerve like a box of Alpha
brain right now for brain
function without it. Um, we're
watching the Brazil broadcast,
but I have UFC fight pass so we can,
uh,
we can watch the Moose saucy versus Munoz
fight, which has already taken place.
You know what happened?
You're a friend, a friend,
and a fan of a good dude.
It's a tough one, man.
Musashi live like a fucking beast.
We'll, we'll come to that later. Well,
he took them down.
You want to watch it real quick while
we're waiting for the fights over here so
my neck doesn't hurt. It's not possible.
No, I'll show you the, this is,
this is the end.
It's pretty much this.
You're saying Munoz could
take it right behind you.
Munoz tried to take them down.
Watch. He tried to take him down,
got him to the ground, got inside
control, went for the Guillotine,
wound up being on top and uh,
eventually got his back from out
to them. Yeah, it was pretty slick.
Mark Turns did. He's good. He's
fucking really good. You know,
a lot of people sleep on his ground game,
man.
They think about him as a kickboxer. They
shouldn't, it, his ground game is very,
very high level and it was a sweet
transition to the way you did it.
You know, Munoz is, uh, he's no
joke. You know, he's a good wrestler,
very strong guy and move saucy
for him to do this to him.
This was a NCAA champ, right? Two Times
in a row, four time. All American.
Listen with Munoz in practice,
this is the same thing he
does when he gets the mount.
He goes for that single leg and
it causes them a lot of trouble.
So he would work with here on
Henner about options not to do that,
but it's just in his nature when the
bullets are flying to turn the wrestling,
he gets him in trouble, man. Yeah. Well,
that is the transition
that a lot of guys make,
especially when they feel like they're
super dominant wrestlers and they feel
like, look, I'm already where I want
to be. I can just complete this single.
But while he's, he was going for, uh,
the takedown Musashi hit him with
some nasty fucking elbows. Man.
They were really ugly,
really ugly elbows and uh,
I think those probably took a lot out
of him. Man. Those were horrible elbows.
Oh, what a sweet move, man.
So he couldn't, he couldn't,
I was quite taken down and get on top.
The out grappled flattens.
What does your Sassy is, is, is that
a, an Iranian name? Persian name?
I think it is. Maybe Armenian.
You know, I'm not sure.
It sounds, uh, oh, that's
me. That's Joey. Oh Shit.
Let's find out. Tough man. Sucks to watch.
Yep.
You rock your live. Joey.
Do you live Joey Diaz?
[inaudible]
phone call baby.
He's Armenian.
Did you watch the Munoz slide? Oh,
he hung up. He probably lost him
saying that is funny. You
know, just asking if kiss was,
that's how funny Joey,
like
maybe like 15 years ago,
that's something you can Google or
hall of fame.
I don't think so.
Getting frozen yogurt,
I'm getting pregnant with a beautiful
blonde a while back and gene Simmons is
sitting down as I come back
in to get like Vanilla Yogurt.
I said,
I'm going to get one and she's outside
and I go on and he looks at me and he
goes, he goes and I go, hey
man, how are you doing? I go,
it's like your friend. Very
cute. Like you're feeling
friend, something like that.
And I go and I go, I said, yeah, yeah,
it's great man. Yeah, it's amazing.
I'm just thinking about it.
You guys been doing this for 20 years,
you've been taught, you know, I'm
famous for 20 years and he goes 30 30.
I was like, right, right, right.
Okay. And that was the end of that.
It's high by the way, doing stand
up for him. That was it. Well,
doing Santa for him at the,
uh, MMA awards, like he's in
the front row. I think he,
I,
he didn't quite laugh,
but he did open his mouth a couple
of times and kind of looked at me.
Yeah. He kind of went out to one
of the most nervous I've ever been.
He came to see me on New Year's Eve. He
brought his family. That's nerve wracking.
Simmons, his brother and
his or his son rather. Uh,
who's funded six, eight giant kids.
All families. John, I was like,
their child a basketball is like, they
want you in a content is tall. Yeah.
Yeah. They're big humans. But
it was the weirdest thing ever.
It's like gene Simmons is in the crowd.
Like Gene Simmons kind of like,
Oh fuck yeah it does. I
tearing it up. I brought,
I brought it up and call them out. I had
to happen, had to for me, I was like,
I just got to tell you I'm nervous.
Well that's like I couldn't stand up.
I did stand up for,
for Harvey Cartel and Harry Dean Stanton
and there in the audience to see me.
Oh my God. I was, I was nervous
man. I found myself very
nerve Bieber in the crowd.
Yeah.
I wasn't nervous about,
oh, I saw you. You were shitting
your pants on Biba. Yeah.
Right. You sent me a text.
I got beavers hair.
Right.
What does Bieber, who's got the tattoo
with Floyd? He's hanging out with Floyd.
That's the problem. Come
on. Does he have to do
just be cool and fucking sing?
Don't act all tough. Tough.
Would it be,
I agree with all of you.
I don't think he's doing anything wrong.
I think if I was 19 I would be one
way more out of control.
If I had a half
the kids,
the kids doing fan fucking tasks,
so he ne he egged the neighbor's house,
whatever.
He's in a fight with an asshole
who lives next door to him.
I probably have indentured servants
I'd be out of out of you will think,
why not people killed his
next door. Neighbors would
be like 10 miles away, dude.
No, no, no, no. That's it.
Living next to books is a very
crowded community. I mean, Joe
and I am, I'm going to join.
I wanted to get a pit bull
Joe and I like idiots found,
I find this advertisement. It says
pitbulls bread right out of the box.
I was like the Joe. He goes,
what? I go, I found fighting dogs.
I want Charles on the end of a
leash was like, I'll come with you.
We'd go find that sketchy dude.
Catch the sketchy criminal, like,
oh yeah. I don't know if he's selling
it, but he's definitely, he gave his dog.
He was giving these talk is protein
powder. I was like, all right,
well I want one of those.
Yeah, it was great. Yeah,
kind of until it killed a baby cow and
two goats and a and another dog and then
they had to put it down.
Dogs are not good pets.
They're sweet as hell. And
then I just gave bread gain.
Brendan, the ones that are,
look, it's on the genetics man. 100% of
the genetics. I would have had a pitch,
so if I was Justin Bieber at that age,
I would have sort of Justin Bieber.
I'd have lions. Yeah. Fuck yeah. We can
think about what Tyson had. If you, uh,
it depends entirely on the dog,
but even if you soup,
like if you're really good
at like taking your dog
to dog parks and getting them
used to being around people,
they still have mad animal aggression,
aggression trigger.
You never know what them, what dom Irrera
when Justin Bieber was in the audience,
dumb Americans.
I mean,
cause you know Justin and
must've been really hard for you.
The struggle between the age of 13 and
14 when you were a man. By the way.
I still worse Damo railroad impression
that Justin beaver movie never surrender.
Never give up.
I believe when you're fly I
the one to see it. I said,
let's go watch that in goof
on it and we'll record.
We'll just goof on this stupid ass
movie like Justin Bieber movie.
I couldn't wait to watch it and goof on
it. But when you go and you watch it,
you man, when you, when you know
the story of how he blew up,
it's when you actually know how
to youtube. It's pretty crazy.
I thought he was a,
uh,
a producer project or like some labels
putting together. They did not want.
They didn't, nobody wanted to sign him.
He blew up on his own from Youtube.
How just cause he was so good. He's,
he's in a fucking amazing singer.
He can sing his ass. He plays
drums. He plays guitar in that.
Let's let everyone knows. Her fight is
about to start. If you're watching this,
the, here's the problem.
If you watch this online,
it's a 15 second delay between us.
This is what I had to get out between
when we're talking to the fights.
The fights are at Verde happened
by the time you're hearing this.
So pause like 15 seconds
and then catch up.
Right now it's four 51 of the first round.
You should apply.
Let honey Jason and Robbie Pearl.
I'm not, I'm not mad at those.
Ring card girl is the new
Brazilian rent cars. Got Pow POW.
Did you get to thing on a shoulders?
Might be a little much.
She just couldn't get out of that
on a tee shirt instead. But honey,
Jason's a bad motherfucker and he's,
yeah, he's a wild man. He got in Brazil.
All right. Jeremy Stevens knocked
him out with a head kick, but he uh,
he came back with a wind.
His next fight after that,
Jeremy Stevens hit them
with the kick from hell.
I wonder how we got that
name homies and well, oh,
Jason's his nickname.
That's why he wears the hockey mask.
I wonder how we got that one.
Has anybody ever asked him the
ultimate fighter tattoo? Yeah, he won.
He won the first season of the
Brazilian show. That that right.
If that's a left or a right,
right. Looks like if he,
if he throws it and commenced,
it's going to connect.
What are you talking about son?
Please? Can we mute him when he goes,
hey man, it was all of the UFC
fighter. Please talk to Brian.
Brian. Never say things
like that. And guys,
if you're going to comment on the fight,
you got to do it in a Brazilian accent.
Okay. You fee if you connect
with the ride like that,
there's going to be a pro Arnold
[inaudible] shitting on his dominant rare
impression. Oh, they're on the Brown. Oh,
transition trying for an
arm bar. Got a little, hi
honey. Jason falls off the top. He's
nice and loose. He's keeping loose.
Robbie Peralta, he's a tough motherfucker.
This is going to be a good fight.
This is an interesting fight.
He kinda looks like if Dan
Hardee and Jens Pulver had a kid.
Yeah. Or actually I think, I think
it's Tom Hardy. Chuck laid out.
Yeah. Both of those work. Yeah, it looks
there's a lot of Dan Hartigan there. Yeah,
there is
Dan Harlow with Jens Pulver.
He's good looking kid hardy.
Some chick hardy got pregnant.
Oh.
Oh Damn. I sneak. That was sweet.
What were you saying about pregnant chicks
though, before that elbow happened? No,
I was just getting into the
story of this background. Oh,
how he became looked like that.
I'll make a call right now.
If he catch, he's going to
catch them with that. Right.
That's spinning elbow
was fucking magnificent.
Tastic gonna catch him with the rice. You
know, you didn't see it common either.
He didn't, it didn't telegraph
it. He threw it. It was
beautiful and it was also,
it was unexpected. Did you guys
see some of the prelims? Yeah.
Did you see? Watch the hydro damn
fight. Yeah. What did you say?
Did you see a god? Who was it homeboy? Um,
they're just throwing caution to the wind.
Stopped the fight and the second
round? No. Which fight was it onto?
The first ones? Nope. Was the first
one on Fox. Oh Man, I missed him.
But a standing ovation would probably be
able to get that standing ovation from
Joe Silva. Wow. Which is hard
to do. It's not for what?
Five Joe Joe Silver first
fight on Fox sports one.
He's a real kind of sore that Joe Silva,
that mother fucker know,
seen a couple of fights in his day.
He knows about every fighter
on the planet at all times.
That sounds ridiculous.
But he basically does anytime a guy,
he's like making it into the big leagues.
Silva knows about it.
He's like a super fan and I love
talking to him about fights.
He trains too and he's always trained.
Yeah.
But I love talking to him about fights.
Me and him have some really interesting
conversation about fights. Yeah.
Oh, he put them in that arm
bar? No, he put me in an arm,
but I know he did it. No,
he didn't sit around. They were
just, no, no, not for real. For Real.
No.
You wanted to try out Joe
Joe's way bigger than that.
Show me some new variation.
Armbar and it wasn't effective.
You didn't repeat
real meat head stuff.
I was, you know, was he
was, he had a good idea.
Dia.
It's just he didn't take into account a
couple things and one of them was that
he wasn't controlling my body. I was
like, I'm not you. You don't know.
And it was a, it was a decent idea of
50 pounds of muscle on him that helped.
So no matter what,
if he would've put on a traditional
Brazilian Carlos Gracie senior Armando
still to slip
you gotta you gotta mid sized dog on him,
you could just add,
that's how much more weight
you have on it. We were, uh,
we were talking about, um,
Steve Maxwell was in here and he was
talking about how he had this dude who was
this gigantic football player.
It's just total super athlete,
280 fucking pounds,
pure muscle NFL player college where we're
talking to college. No, no, no, it was,
I forget, I forget. I think
either way. I think it was a a,
I think it was a NFL player,
but anyway, giant dude. Right.
And the a was rowing with one of his
brown belts and the guy gets him in a
mounted arm bar mount some takes his arm
fully locked in arm bar and they'd do
it. Stands up with them like
a Turkish getup. All my God,
all my arm over there and they were
like, don't slam. I'm dot. Oh my God.
I'm going to let him go. Let him go. Put
him down, put him down. Everybody backs.
Let them know it was just, there was,
it was so much stronger than it did.
Like the other dude was only,
or like a buck 60 he was so much
stronger than it was. Just insanity.
I just had some about Andre Carter who
played defensive end for the 40 niners
and for the past,
and I just met him.
He's six seven two 65 and just
the most ridiculous athlete.
And I always do this. How'd you
think you're doing the UFC? Huh?
Big Guy. Huh? Duwan EFC or
fuck no man, he get tore up.
He get wrong. Yeah, the enlist
and people are always like,
oh how it NFL elite athletes,
Lebron James.
It takes a special kind of athlete to
get punched in the face the first day in
the gym. Like you know what? I want to
do more of this. I'm gonna come back,
look at that elbow.
Look at this album.
Oh and there's not a million
dollar signing bonus jam.
I was hoping they were
going to show that again.
That elbow was goddamn beautiful.
Yeah. No million dollar signing bonus.
Super Dangerous. A long way. Very
nothing guaranteed. High risk.
Very low potential reward.
What it is is football players and any
professional athlete really they will,
if they got into Jujitsu
or if they got into MMA,
they will progress a lot
quicker than your average guy.
Cause they have the athleticism balance.
So that's what it was like. Will it,
does he have the whole package?
The mental package,
the work ethic and the technique,
the heart shit.
And because of the fact
that it's not a guarantee,
you got to be looking for glory.
You really have to be doing it for glory.
You can't really be mine it for money.
You gotta be doing it to get really
fucking good at and be Gloria. Listen,
there's a lot of guys who in the NFL
who I played with are in college and
there's some guys in fine too,
but mainly in these other sports where
they would walk away from if they could.
They hate doing it. They
hate playing football. It's
just the money. So damn good.
Rolled with some elite football
players. Oh yeah. Yeah.
I mean some big powerful guys used to
have at the gym. Who is that dude who was,
I don't know what level
football he played, but uh,
I used to always call rolling with him.
It was like riding liberal,
driving the ball, rolling with them.
You know what I'm talking about?
How many Alpha brain should I
take? Four. I take nine. Yeah,
give me and I take four floors.
Do you remember the Guy I'm talking about?
I want to take the football player, Eddie.
Uh, football, big black guy. Super strong.
Really flexible. No, wasn't
handy. Old Legends did. Yeah.
All logins old. The BRAYA
legends? Yes. Football player. Oh,
Leanne Macklin. I think that's him.
Yeah. He played running back in college.
Oh my God. This guy was an
athlete. Ridiculous. He's
learning Jujitsu, but athlete.
But it was like riding the bull.
He was just so fucking strong.
I'll tell you what I mean.
Shane.
Shane Carwyn was 300 pounds when I first
started with him and he would, you know,
Shane would, he'd go do his
job. He'd be gone having Andrew,
he'd be gone for six weeks and I'd be
working on Jujitsu three times a day,
seven days a week. I'm like, I can't
wait for Shane to get back. I'm a role,
this big Mug,
that thing that he's just so bad.
Nothing like you said, you'd strap
something on him. He just fricking,
her Kelly is out of honey.
Jason just mounted Robbie Peralta and
Robbie Paul to explode in his car.
He's talking real quick.
It was a good move. Both of
these guys are tough. Hey Man,
every guy,
see tonight's going to be pretty
sweaty if some of his,
uh,
is a sweat a lot.
They got a lot of muscle mass.
This guy has a little car to say.
These guys have a lot of muscle on them.
This guy's a stud. They like fighting
these guys. These guys fight.
These guys are fighting.
Ooh.
Oh. Tries to a Omoplata
lost it. Lost Control.
Try it needs to learn some rubber guard
like that shit until it doesn't work on
these guys guys. A lot of stuff
doesn't work. These guys exercise.
I saw natural shit's totally natural.
Can I be honest? Fighting hurts.
It hurts for anybody out there.
Robbie Peralta on top kicking haunted
Jason in the legs. It's got to hurt.
Interesting way. She fibers it.
Never know like how long to to stand
there and when to step them back up.
Obviously homeboy, he doesn't want
to go to the ground with them.
So you might say, I think you should
probably stand up possible. Right?
But it's a tricky situation.
It's like,
remember you used to watch those old Jack
Dempsey films and that he would knock
a dude down then hover over.
Cause when the guy tried to get back up,
you'd punch up and people would be like,
oh that's so cheap. That's so cheap.
You know, they used to be able to do that.
That's some cheap shit. Now you have to,
you know,
stand in neutral corner and the boxer
has to wait for the guy to get up.
But it's kind of unrealistic.
So when you see a scenario like this,
I think it's kind of interesting.
Peralta was, you know,
holding his legs and kicking them
and they're beautiful right hand.
That was nice.
That didn't hurt.
You see how he said come in and
he got hit the minute he got hit,
he started doing that. The a hydro
ego damned fight earlier. Um,
he was fighting, what's his
name? Never met her. Never
good. Madoff. I believe it is.
You're asking me to remember it when you
see Paulo Thiago so many lost another
one. He Paul. Tiago does. Yeah.
Damn. Who did he lose to today?
Some Russian cat. Did. I don't,
I think he's lost. He's lost.
That was going on with Thiago Silva. Like
that whole situation. Oh, Thiago Silva.
Yeah. Yeah. Um, apparently, uh, you know,
he got arrested and they kicked
him out of the UFC. Right. And uh,
he had a gun on him or something.
You know,
I don't know if he actually brought it up.
I'll tell you right now what this all
stems from his chicken live chicken is
chip.
No
job's going to drop some fucking chicken
head signs. Have you never heard shot?
He's like, oh, he hit that beautiful
fun. He took it as he took the Jab.
He spun and landed at all. But just loving
it and look at it. Oh, nice. Left Hook.
Next slide. Oh, I need, oh
right hand by honey. Jason.
Great. Right button. Proud to just
outfit. Oh, well this is a great fight.
They said, defense, you're outta here.
Let's just throw it. They let it go.
Brendan shot. We'll give a master
course under shaking heads,
shaking heads one oh was he will
hear your version and chicken heads.
It's a lot of people out there that will
ruin their fucking life with the wrong
person.
You hang out with the wrong people.
Brendan Walsh would teach her how to
avoid chicken heights. Simple Walsh.
I say it all the time. Brendan Frasier,
who's Brendan Brennan? Wallace.
Brendan Frasier. Brendan Schaub
apparently has a piece on him.
Heard that from girl.
Mm. I believe you have a,
you should do like one of those
late night infomercials on chicken.
It's chicken heads.
Do you have chicken and just show a
bunch of like different scenarios.
What would that song you could use you
to hear his song on your one album?
Boudou per nanny. It was kind of
stuff that guys, that was good.
That wasn't terrible. It's just
a good song. It was that day. Oh,
you got to hear it. That's a good
song. Don't tell yourself, well,
you know we haven't talked. We haven't
been in since UFC one 73 Oh yeah.
Tj Dillashaw. Damn. Those
incredible, right. Inspiring.
Look at how he eats the jab and
spins. Ooh, what was a right hand?
He ate the right hand. Oh, nice. Jumping
knee. To really wild fight. Why Walmart?
Mario ain't having it. Come
on. He's excited. Yeah,
they were just going to high five.
You know we get chilled though there.
They enjoyed the fight. They didn't
join it. I says God did. Yeah.
I like when the dudes do that. They must
have trained before together. Oh No,
they're just having a great fucking time.
They're just having a great fucking
time. That was a while. Wouldn't do that.
Mr. Brennan Shab.
Most boxers wouldn't do that either.
A lot of people wouldn't do that.
It's rare. You know what might happen?
Like one half of 1% of all UFC fights.
Risky kick.
When you do that could you could catch
an elbow. You know why you don't do that?
You ever seen Pat Barry vs Mirko Cro cop
when he kept hugging and grabbing each
other's nuts and shit. Yeah,
but you don't do very extreme.
That was a very extreme version of, well,
I'm just saying. That's one example.
I don't, then I had to fight
Mirko Cro cop after that.
Not The way you show respect man.
What do you mean like show respect?
I beaten him up by bringing it to them,
not by high five them and have them
sign your shorts inside the octagon.
That's what I do. I'd be
friends with everybody. You
know what I'm saying? Yeah. No,
I know what you're saying. You
can be friends afterwards. Yeah.
Well I think Pat Barry was actually
good friends with Mirko Cro cop. Right.
They trained together, but
still get it. I get it.
I and Andre Arlovski. You train together.
You think we're high fiving? Nah.
You think we're touching gloves?
Nope. Well, were you friends with her?
Lawsky we were good training partners,
man.
Did you guys ever go looking for honeys?
Hey, you are fighting for chicken heads.
He was, he had it. He had a
girl. You're a good person.
He had when when you went to touch gloves.
He goes, no, we'll do it afterwards.
It did. Wow. Then he woke up. I tried
shaking his hand. He didn't want to,
Geez. Oh pokes. God. It's the worst
fucking so what do they do about it?
There's nothing you can really do about
it. Did you have to change those gloves?
Man.
That's one thing to make all curved.
Make the gloves so that it
accentuates the hand. Why curves? Yup.
That's a nice shot there. Oh God.
Enjoy your victory. One fricken,
I write in the fuck.
Oh Man.
It's such a terrible injury
that you know what I also think,
I think they haven't exhausted all the
possibilities as far as like covering the
tips of the fingers. Everybody says
you have to have the fingers open.
What about covering the tips was like a
very thin sort of like a piece of tough
leather or grappling, bro. Well, this is
what I'm thinking. Wouldn't it actually,
if it was like Suede or
something along those lines,
what did it actually probably give you
just a little more grounded, right?
They would come off. No, no,
I'm not saying it's thimbles.
I'm saying the front end of the glove,
the way it's constructed.
Some sorta like lambskin
or some sort of pliable.
Something's flyable little not,
not like kangaroo
kangaroo
lambskin.
I've never tried one. Yeah,
no. Yeah, I have. They make
clothes out of it too though.
They make. They make sauce.
Smells like it. Smells like soup.
You've tried it didn't break off.
I'm a little confused on what he's
talking about. Condoms. Lambskin condoms.
Have you ever tried them? I have
never heard of him. I have never heard
any more because they have
microscopic holes. Get HIV,
can get through it.
In Africa it was the original condom.
The original condoms are made out of
animal like in depth sense. Yeah, totally.
Yeah.
I mean that's what they use.
You guys have bang in animal intestines
actually feel way better apparently.
Yeah. I'm all set on that Bro.
I'm all set. That's why the Lens,
another podcast [inaudible]
tried out a real doll. They went, they
took turns on the real doll on the shop.
Had the real dawn in another
room like like in that room,
whatever and were miked and
they took turns on the real though. I
don't think, I think Howard got the mouth.
I think that's all he was like,
I'll do it,
but you got to carry you the mouth.
Everybody gets a different,
I'd love to hear Brian.
Good fight. Yeah. Got,
sorry man.
Sorry guys.
There's guys out there that hang
out and doubled team real dollars.
You gotta get your own Bro. You
know what? They're too expensive.
I guarantee there's two dudes have
right now. Listen to this podcast.
Double teaming. Some dogs all
jacked up on bulletproof coffee.
I got to be right. There's gotta be
dudes in a parties with it. Like fuck it.
Let's do it like one dude.
He could afford like a real good one.
I'll tell you what my post fight
party is right now. Well they have
these websites where these guys take
the real dolls and dress him up and a,
I'm mocked it and this
is how I know I used to,
I just think it was funny to make fun of
real dolls. But then this dude told me,
oh he get poked to no, he's
blowing his nose. They told me, um,
this guy sent me an email like angry at
me and then I sent him an email back.
Like, Hey, you know, look,
I'm just trying to be funny.
I'm sorry if it hurt your feelings,
you know,
but you realize it's kind
of funny like the people,
cause he was like in love with it. Well
he has, it's his girlfriend, you know,
and these guys they draw, treat these
things like they're the girlfriend.
So then he explained to me that he's
who's disfigured when he was young and his
whole life has been like lonely and
sad women find him disgusting and that
that's a lot of the
guys in this community.
Oh Shit. That's kind of heartbreaking.
It's totally a different point of view.
I would definitely have a doll. I was
fucked up and cause he really interesting.
I think I was taking it.
Yeah.
In terms of, you know, like
some crazy dude cause angst.
That's a girl and that it's some,
it's you're a madman.
If you think that's a girl.
Well that's a different situation.
I was,
I was thinking if you're a regular duty
of your shit together and you're going
home taking out a doll, you need
a fucking motivational talk, man.
Send me a text and I'll give
you a motivational talk.
What's the whole fucking movie where
a dude fell in love with Ryan Gosling
called Lars and the real
girl as I don't know, but uh,
that movie her where she fought,
where he falls in love with the,
I love that movie.
It was so good.
There's got to be 70 of them.
He's like a pimp. He has them all
out in his living room and shit.
He comes out with a fucking smoking
jacket and he's got all these real dogs.
He sleeps with like 10 of them and shit.
Oh for sure.
It was going to be the oldest one,
at least one did.
And all the guys in his community there
like jealous of them and shit. Fuck.
He's got so many shit.
Those things are expensive. There's
got to be guys out there they want,
they just can't afford one.
They just $10,000 for their
10 g's or something like that.
Five G's. 10 genes. That's a lot of money.
Yeah. They're probably pretty expensive.
We weren't even paying
attention a little bit. I'll do
worse than the fucking judges in
Vegas if you try to judge that.
I was actually watching.
I got to know Jason. I got
Jason. You would not watch it.
I was to be other people's real dolls
off like breaking in and stealing and
shit.
Like give me back my real dog.
They break in while he's at
work, they break in flower. Real
brands have a tenant. They
just, my friends have to
evict this tenant from their,
from their apartment because the
guy was breaking the other tenants,
uh,
spit it out.
Apartments the other women and stealing
their clothes and all those women who
are going, I'm missing my
clothes. What's going on?
So one girl put up video cameras and
the guy was breaking in during the day,
stealing. So they get to his
place and these guys just bins,
bins full of women's stuff and he dresses
up in his house and walks around and
Oh my God, that's what he's into. And
now, now the cops, you know, you're crazy.
If you don't take an order,
a doll,
it looks like Joe Rogan and
guys are fucking it. I'm crazy.
Even crazier than that.
How about the fact that they're going
to have artificial robot bodies that you
can fuck right there that's
going to happen. Where
can we find out where they're at? Are
they close, slow? With synthetic biology,
they might be able to make great.
That's very real feeling robots.
It could be a person. I mean, you could
essentially be an artificial person,
so you're going to be able
to fuck a Brendan Schaub.
You'll be able to fuck big foot
Silva [inaudible] gay dudes.
They just maybe so just want to get
savaged by my bad ass dude. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. I bet.
I bet you could probably order real dolls
that looked like scarlet Johanson and
show. Yeah, well, yeah,
but I think you're going to be able
to order an exact duplicate of scarlet
Johannson. I mean, it's going
to be so strange. Stupid.
That's the world's going to be stupid.
I would order one if it was
affordable and reasonable.
If you talk to someone who lived in the
14 hundreds about Internet porn on your
phone, they would look at you. Look, you
were completely raw. He Won. Peralto. Wow,
that doesn't make sense. Big Win. Well,
I don't know if you were to really
truly paying attention there.
We were talking about definitely not
watching it enough to accurately judge a
fight. What is high a Bussa it's a company
that makes clothes closing gear. Yeah.
Boxing gloves and shit. Good
gear down. Yeah. I don't know.
Did they pay you Brian to
say that he has say $10,000.
Here's a random, here's a, I don't
know how to sit and see this,
but you weren't really, totally none
of that landed that move of the night.
None of those landed. Nope. Nope. Nope.
He's going against. So that couldn't
have hurt you made the I didn't hurt.
It didn't me.
It was a good fight. It was a really
good point. Did anyone watch the uh,
the fridge and groves boxing match? No,
but I watched the knockout. Good flight.
Yeah. I didn't use case. Biggest
boxing match all tiny thousand people.
[inaudible] stadium. Crazy man. The
biggest of all time. Isn't that funny?
That Kroll fraud is so big over
in England, but people in America,
the average sports fan is no idea.
I don't know.
I'll tell you who knows who he is.
His girl,
she is dime piece of the girl and he won
that belt, but his girl jumped in there.
Everyone was like, Dang.
Dang. Lang Lang a frosh.
His girlfriend, she's, he's
winning. He is winning everybody.
Yes. God is real strange.
You know I was on the,
on a plane with Vladimir Klitschko and
nobody bothered him at all. Insane. Right?
He walked in, he sat down, nobody knew
who he was and I was like, Holy Shit.
And so I'm like watching to see if
people tweak and start pointing at him
nothing and go, Holy Shit. That's the
heavyweight champion of the world. Nope.
Not a single person who was white, but
in Europe all over, he can't go anywhere.
He's like, Tom Cruise here. He could
deliver your pizza. You're like, oh,
what's up dog? Well, he lives in
Germany and him and his brother,
they did a lot of time in Germany.
They lived in Germany
for a long time and they,
they speak German and they were like
beloved in Germany. Smart Dude. Yeah.
Really smart. They're fucking PhDs. Yeah.
It's kind of crazy that guys with super
high education would be the hazy on the
eyes. Too easy on the eyes. Perfect
genetics. No big deal. Yeah.
But you know, he lost a bunch of
times. He's an interesting case man.
He lost a bunch of times and uh,
another eye gouge man.
What do you know at a
certain point time man,
someone's got to do something about
these guys. Part of the sport. Right.
Is it though? I mean he can this like
people getting kicked in the nuts.
You'd be like, man, we have to stop ice
or take it out. A way to do it though.
If you ever tried one
of those a diamond cups,
those diamond and my makeup's nope.
You told me about it last time.
I thought I was going to get
one in the mail. I get you one.
I'm going to every techstars,
these diamond directly in the
balls every single time. Dude goes,
hold on a second. Hold on.
Hold on one second. Yeah.
Off the top of my head. Oh, there we go.
Two matches that ended with ball shots.
Oh yeah. Underlay Gilbert.
Ival remember that pride 11,
he kicked him in the balls and he just
couldn't recover cause his ball got
caught and guys were never the same man.
Kind of have to kick him.
Most of the time though in MMA from,
from what I remember,
you get kicked in the balls. That doesn't
end. The fight might, they might be true.
You get five minutes to recover
Gilbert idol. It was done in one that,
and I didn't recover from that when his
ball was sticking out. Oh, got crushed.
And that's the only one I remembered.
You guys remember any fight
ended because of a bunker shot.
I don't fight fights end
because of I got this right.
How many invented and you can detach.
We'll get them out.
Anthony Johnson ended because of the eye
gouge. The Anthony Johnson fight was,
it was a bad one. Phil Davis, uh,
fought that one dude. Brazil. Yeah,
that's what they stopped
the fight veto. Uh,
who has a [inaudible] against a grand
tour, but that was a different thing.
That was actually a good lunch slice.
The upper eyelid like his eyelid was open,
like you could like could
keep his eyes closed.
You could see his eyeball through
us. Yeah. And it was from a punch,
like the grazing of the uh,
side of the glove did that,
I think you just got to chalk it up,
man. Part of the sport. You say that,
but have they looked at all the options?
Because I feel like people can
figure something out. First of all,
Tim Kennedy said they should use the pride
gloves. Jamie, go, go grab some there.
They're in the back. I had
him. I just for this, uh,
for this discussion they cover the
fingers a little more, a little more,
but they accentuate the curve.
Apparently according to Jackie
Kennedy keep you in this position,
whereas the UFC gloves, you actually
have to stress to close your hand.
Here it is right here. This is the,
this is the official Prague love.
This is from Brian London.
Real what? That makes sense,
right on real curve. If you
want to straighten it, you can,
but you've got to force it.
Yes, that's a very good, well,
and then Everlast recently developed
a glove for Bella tour that they're
allowing the UFC to use. There's
definitely more covering the fingers.
Everlast the rapper,
like my man is a bad
motherfucker entrepreneur. Um,
he um, they developed a, a a glove,
the Bella towards using where it covers
like it makes the hand bend more.
I get some more formed like a
fist and Allen and yeah. But yeah,
I think even more so maybe even
better than the pride one. But the uh,
the pride when our like the fingers
don't spread apart as much. Like look,
when you open your hand, put Po, hold
your hand up like that. See it seems like,
it seems like there's a little more
coverage of the fingers a little bit more,
a little longer, a little longer.
Damien Maia, Alexander Jako Lev,
who is him? What his big so
beautiful. I don't know. I don't,
I'm not aware. Um, I'll look it
up real quick. But this a real,
the struggle is real to get this glove on.
But
is there more padding on these though
then in UFC gloves and look three tickets
and they go on.
I want to just start walking around and
thinking of the same way.
What is it
legit. I box today with Wayne McCullough.
You, I've been boxing a lot this week.
Yes I have. They do have a little more
patent on the front. Like you said,
your hands are curved.
You want to hear something random,
you know the nods commercial with the,
uh,
the guy with the Mohawk who
gets knocked out and the guy,
I took a lesson at revolution MMA in a,
in Toronto from that guy who
knocks him out the Moitai lesson.
It was really cool. Yeah.
And you know Joe Gerson,
Joe the Guy [inaudible]
Satoh you're that guy.
You're steering. Your
stories are hurting, bro.
I'm trying to,
when
we talked about it last night when we
talked about last out of the instructors
and the guy is the guy, you're
the good, listen, listen,
there's a million guys out there who
train and we're tap out shirts that look
exactly. That was him. He was him. Well
that's what he told you like I have no,
we talked about it.
That's a claim to fame.
People get mad when you call it like
there's people aligned to get mad when we
do fun. Brian. Oh, I know bullying.
You're bullying Brian. I know
you guys bully Brian. There's a,
you have a reputation
for that. Yes, we did
podcasts.
We did.
We actually got tweets that were accusing
us of people don't understand ball
busting. Like I don't know if
you guys don't have to. Yeah,
but you guys who are freaking out
because we bust each other's balls. Yeah,
go get some friends. Also also also very
sensitive if you haven't noticed. Yeah,
well you don't understand.
He likes it like half of the
reason why he acts retarded,
so they will call them on it. It's
not so subtle. It's not very subtle,
ladies and gentlemen, if you're freaking
out and attaching that much to do too,
obviously like hanging out
with each other. I don't know.
Maybe you have friends at home that you
don't really like and we'll try. I mean,
I do go home and cry,
but that's not the case.
Brian cries at night.
I do in my hands or you can
come down to abot. Kenny,
you're down there. Let you feel like
Brian Killen. You'll show me around.
Mr Kellan can have some of that
delicious one. I friend. I,
that's what I brought it for.
Eddie. Do you want some wine?
Because somebody is training right
now so they can't have it. Mr a man.
I'll tell ya Brandon shop don't
get his way when he's hungry. Oh,
less than two weeks away. Brendan. Shop
go time go time. How you a baby? Good man.
Ready to go.
I've never been more excited for a flight.
Get some why Eddie go get a
glass right in to solve the, uh,
the trailer to see the trailer
that Lincoln Park release
where you'll see one 74.
No, I watched that. And you will be amped.
Really. Lincoln Park did. They can park.
Yeah. Holy Shit. It's dope.
Dana white tweeted out. Yeah,
they played it on the wall.
You're obviously working,
but they played it on a UFC one 73 and
I was watching it with some buddies and
um, I don't know. Things got
real. It's like, Oh shit,
we're two weeks away here, boy. Ready
Baby. Wow. Your main card, right? Yeah,
of course. Just like asking
dumb questions. Yeah. Yeah.
Why don't you play it and have you
found it? I mean, he'd go Lincoln Park,
UFC one 74 standard. Lincoln busted
a, an acoustic set. Not going to lie.
It wasn't who I love.
Lincoln Park Acoustic.
Anyways, they played
this promo and a, yeah,
I didn't say a word for this and
I kind of went never back down.
MMA motivation feature in
Lincoln Park. Is that it? Nah.
You'll see one 74 promo UFC one 74 promo.
Okay. We find get lift and,
hold on, hold on. Alright.
Prom. Well there you go. Yeah, that's it.
Wastelands what's that waste? It's
called Lincoln Park Wasteland. Okay.
Slap that bitch on. Okay,
I'll do it here. Yeah.
Wastelands
and then you see out stack.
This card is one 74 that it is.
Anyway, back to my story about taking
a lesson from, would you say that,
okay,
now you got to go back and you
click the wrong video. I did
go backwards.
It was the second one.
Yeah, that's it. Wait, hold on.
What's that? Yeah, I muted it already.
The second one. Wastelands preview.
Okay, here we go. Yeah,
that's it. Wasteland. There
it is. I don't give a shit.
Where am I hearing that?
You got to hear the music, man. This
isn't it. Why is this your truck?
Can I shut this off?
I'm gonna shut the Ustream off.
Where am I hearing that
from? Chinese. What?
This guy is six three one 70 what's that
tall man? Oh, there's two
windows open. That's what it is.
Okay. Let me play this for you
guys to wastelands preview.
Hope Damien Maia uses Jujitsu.
I hit has been striking lately.
Drives me nuts.
The volume is down on that
youtube browser to, Oh, is it?
Well, let's play this when the
fights out on good call. Cause I'm,
I'm a mess here.
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
Nah,
y'all come on Damien Maia.
It's gotta be a big weight cut for
a Damien Maia said it's easier bro.
He just fucking one day. How's they
get sash? He's got some tits on.
Yeah,
he gave him,
I went on that losing streak because
for whatever reason you have this
worldclass Jujitsu and they're like,
you know what I like striking.
I'm not going to take guys down. I just
want to strike. Yeah. It's crazy to me.
I get on these rugs tag Mark
Munoz and hurt him, you know,
and I think he fall in love with it,
getting better at it,
but he still uses it.
You just feel like now he is.
Now he's at one sandwich
store 85 he wasn't. Yeah,
the Rick story fight was incredible.
I remember when he toss chill Sona
and landed in that mounted triangle.
I was so sick.
Yeah.
I think it's so scary for
a lot of Brazilian Jujitsu
practitioners to get in to
MMA and all of a sudden some dude's
trying to fucking knock them out.
It's scary.
So when,
when they get to the point where they
actually can do it and they're getting hit
and they're like, fuck, there's
nothing to be scared of.
And even though they lose
decisions, I think they, I
think they like it. You know,
I think like Georgia Shell, he's
losing decisions, but he's like, fuck,
I'm not afraid of this shit. I'm a
fucking savage. He's getting hit,
he's getting cut up and he
just keeps going forward.
I think that it feels good to them.
He's got [inaudible] feels good or not.
It's got some powder and he
seems to, uh, and especially
when you're awake,
guy like Damien,
Mike gets knocked out inside the octagon
and now we could do it to people. Yeah.
Yeah. So I think they, even though they
lose a decision, they just liked it.
They liked throwing. Here we
go. But it's also, you know,
you got to realize that a guy like Damien
Maia got so fucking good at Jujitsu
because he becomes obsessed
and he probably just assumes
he's going to get that
good at striking.
He was saying that would be his home
base threatening everybody everywhere.
Oh yeah. He has got out there with
his hands like way better, way better,
way better. He's moving. He looks
much more like a striker. Yup.
There's that weird way that grapplers
move when you know they can't strike it
all. It's real awkward. Very stiff. Yeah.
But when you see a guy get that certain
fluidity to them and it's, it's weird.
Like it doesn't always translate that
way cause some guys look kinda awkward,
but they're really good strikers.
I Love Damien Maia because, uh,
I was at a real low point in my life
when I was fighting in Brazil and I was
again, asa yet like two in
the morning after I fought
Nogueira and uh, he came up,
give me a big hug in front of all these
people. Oh, that's cool. Yeah, man.
That's cool. Really cool.
Yeah. It's a very nice guy,
but certain stuff you don't forget, you
know? Yeah. No, that's very cool, man.
So He's doing rolled his Jab,
popping that jab out there,
but he hasn't been able
to get ahold of this.
Russian dude is a master
of sport in both sides.
Mastering, sporting what? Master's son.
It's over master of sport and
Sabo and Jujitsu or it's awesome.
Although that's over big elbow. Good
luck in him off of Mount. Yeah. Yeah.
Two and a half minutes to build sales
mountain is sick. It's a building.
Oof.
Damien Maia said tax book.
She just tell you right now time,
what are the odds that this guy
survives this round? What are the odds?
I'd say they're 50% because our sport
and Sambo and a master sport and
wrestling, I say less than 30% if you
think there's going to be over, yes.
You got to bet money. Yes. I
like that guy. He's a, he's
been, this is a confidence.
10 Bucks, 10 bucks right now that he'll
survive. Okay, I'll take that. But Hey,
10 bucks.
I say nope.
Oh, Damien, I'll bet both of
you. So, okay. I'm saying,
I'm saying he's going to survive. How do
I say the homeboy totally survived? Yeah.
I say survive. Survive. He
looks fresh right now. Look,
you always got to do is he's going to
take Joe's Alamos. He's definitely,
he could get stopped but I think it's a
little bit better than 50% of make it.
It's got a minute 30.
He's going to say he's going to survive.
You guys come on days session
dues are tough as shit son.
I'm still as hard Tom, you got 20 bucks.
Shit, 20 bucks on the line. Yeah, I do.
Yeah. There's so many of these
cats that are Yossi and in um,
there's also guys,
it's a belt or too,
there's some sick Russians
over there as well.
I'll tell you right now when this dude
was getting ready for the game plan for
Damien Maia, they said he's a first round.
Do not let him get on top of you all.
It did set the fan, but it's still,
he's got a minute and got caught. He got
plenty of time for a sick ass arm bar
and he said he might corners and go 30
seconds. You like that though? Up against
the cage. Like that makes it tough. Yeah,
it makes it tough. I have a win win
situation because if I lose your money,
that means Damien Maia. One second
to go on in the wind. So come on.
Damon's gonna win,
but he's going to win in the second
and third is not going to finish.
Dude is too far. He's scared
to tell you that man. Oh,
big elbows. Elbows are ferocious. Oh,
missed him. Estimates that s grip
was pretty triangle coming up.
Sun Hot Triangle coming up.
Hoss Triangle. You got him down.
He guys got it down though.
He's creeping up on the case.
He's going to try to get that is going
to try to get his leg under his head. Oh,
right on man. He's trying
for that. Right? All right.
I thought he had it looked like he
was going to set up front. Triangle.
Elbows are ferocious. I'm a slow
triangle, right? That slow triangle, right
triangle, right. That
bloom. Damien Maia. Damn.
You can't spin to the,
to the [inaudible]. No,
he can't save it. Save it. We're going to,
we're going to get a ride.
I was America fresh 20 point.
I want to take more of your money. Flux
ain't gonna do shit on my life. God,
Eddie Bravo was on fire. He's on fire,
man. It's the Indian one sip of wine.
Indians fucking crashed out right now.
By the way,
I the Instagram picture
of you and Brendan,
you're head is about twice as big as
the heavyweights over here. Yeah. My,
my uncle used to call me moon head.
I always had a big head and
that really like hurt me.
Why you gotta you gotta you
gotta heavyweights head.
So now I call all my head instructors
moon heads cause they're like moons.
So now I turn moon head into
something positive. Changed it.
I regret how training moons in the 10th
Planet System. Where do you teach at?
He's still downtown. It's too far from
me. A lot of seminars to it's too far.
Do you live Monday through Thursday?
Eight 30 to five eight 30
it's too far. I go there. I
just got some Sandiego. Yeah.
How could you say it's too far? I got too
much. Come on down. Come down, man. I got,
I got shot at writing guys.
Between Kung Fu and my step class.
We'll dedicate that glass just to make an,
making sure you leave with something
that you can use in your career.
I will definitely take you up on
that. This is Joe, Joe, Joe, Joe.
Monday to Thursday, eight 30 at night.
No traffic. Boom. He hit downtown.
I got people come on the traffic. Brendan
shrubs or professional. God dammit,
Brian Callen. If you make them walk
across the street to get it, he's too far.
It's too far. I couldn't even go to her
for doing. It was like I could walk there,
make it there. I can't make it. I can't.
I can't guys too far. It's too far.
Hey, you have your invitation.
Remar right? Eddie tomorrow. Yes.
Tomorrow I have a Jujitsu tournament.
I put together a submission only Jujitsu
tournament called Eddie invitational.
It's at the Florentine
Gardens in Hollywood.
If you're anywhere in southern California,
the doors open at 4:30
PM first match goes a at,
it starts at six and we have a one
45 60 men bracket and a one 70 uh,
16 men bracket man.
And we got Gary Tone in at one 70.
Remember the match we talked about him
and Kron Gracie Gary Tone and is the
number one seat at 70 and at one
45, Jeff Glover, he's like, Oh shit,
he's number one at one 45.
So basically he's a beast.
I got some 10 plan of black belts that
are basically going to probably end up in
the finals.
Surprise.
It's going to be Gary or Gary
Tonin against Boogie maybe.
Or uh, if Gary Tone and even gets by
Nathan Orchard, one of my black belts.
Who knows what happens,
but it's, it's going to be
either way and grant match, by the way,
Damien [inaudible] boy pat situation,
you got him down with diem now.
Now let's see. Let's see, mountain,
anyone in the division, he gets
down. No one wants to take it back.
I love the guy doesn't get
out of this round guys.
I say he finishes him right here. No,
I agree. I think he's going to fit.
It's going to finish. What do you think
he's gonna Finish them or survive?
He three minutes. No, no.
He's going to finish him.
I think he's going to finish him. I'm a
contrarian is not going to finish him.
Do it. Rushed out. This guy cannot get
out from under the mountain. Brian.
This is like watching a blue belt
versus a black to that situation.
And I'm not saying that
this guy's a blue belt,
but I'm saying Damien Maia would do the
same to so many black belts, right? Yes,
he's, he's so God damn good. Don't
anything helping. This guy is the cage.
If the cage wasn't there,
Maya would be doing some serious work
if they were in the center. Yeah.
Frank Mir told me that he you like,
this is like Frank Mir is
God damn black belt, right?
Everybody says Frank Mir was buck,
but he told me after he rolled
with with Damien, mind goes,
I'm not really a black vote cause
I'm like a brown belt chase.
It's really said that, wow, you can't
believe how good this guy come on.
And he said he's a 1% or does he tap
frank Mir though? I don't know he,
I didn't ask that. That's disrespectful.
How dare you. Right. But frank is a,
you know,
he's a super smart dude.
Like if you've never had a conversation
with Frank Mir, he's very smart,
very well read,
very well read guy and very honest too.
Like he's not a bullshit artist.
So like when he's,
he's telling you about how good Maya is.
It's come from a
good, he's a good, easily he trapped
that. Did you sweat that? That, that,
that move with the guard was trying to
hip escape and how beautifully Maya made
that transition back to full
mount like this inevitable.
Now he's got him in the middle.
He's got an Mlo who put everything into
trying to get out of that fucking mouth.
Look how good Maya's mount is. This
hooks. He's just controlling his legs,
his knees when he throws the exploding.
Just taking it all. I've got that arm.
See he's not going to,
you can't get out of that shit like you
can with another guy's arm triangle.
Damien Maia has wicked positioning like,
look how good he's close position.
Taking the back. Taking
the back hook. Oh Damn.
I lost it. Oh, shocked. Okay.
He makes it out of this round
now. The guy's going to make it
out or argue with me guys. Yeah,
he's got to make it out there
about me. I know. Fighting. Um,
he's going to take them
down. Maya's rustling. It's
pretty on point now. Now. Oh,
look at this knee attack is this
guy's game. Oh Damn. He's got a name.
He's got a good team. Yeah. He's got an
arm in. Oh No, no. He doesn't have shit.
I mean, the only that's not going
to work on, got an order over.
He might switch a dark. He's got to
be just exhausted, I think. Yeah.
Mine was exhausted. I mean, he really got,
has a submitting Maya's if this
guy is no fucking joke, man. His,
his Jujitsu is no joke though man.
It's good defense. Good defense.
Get in and out of that arm triangle.
You know he,
I mean he couldn't get out of Damien's
mouth, but look, he's still here.
He surviving. He's going to
get swept here. Let's see.
Double under hooks with full guard though.
He's not trying to sweep and we just
hanging on. He tried to his body.
It never makes sense to me. The MMA,
when guys triangle the body from the,
not from the ground, from the back,
from the back of the Mat. Totally.
But from guard, what are you
trying to get? Trying to hang on.
That's what I think he's trying to do.
I think he's trying to decide the rest.
Yeah. If you go for a body,
like he's letting it loose here,
but if you go for a body
triangle and full guard,
you're not trying to set up a submission.
Do you literally can't do anything.
You could start any to stall.
You could let it go yourself show.
The thing about it is you could let
it go yourself like so say yeah.
So say if like a,
if a gay teen presented itself,
you could always get back to full guard,
right?
You could use the real full guard if
somehow or another you could catch some
pain or sickness to do
that. A lot. He was,
he is at the most wholesome strikers are
just like, you ain't passing this guard.
Never and you just cross your ankles
and the guy has a good knee slice.
He could open that shit up.
But when you were putting on the triangle
you're saying, I ain't trying to shit,
I'm just going to hold you and
sometimes you need to do that.
If one of my fighters as well,
it's mostly a striker and his Jujitsu
with just coming along and he,
he was in some amateur MMA fight, I'd
say. Yeah figure for his fucking body.
You know, you don't try no triangles
or I think as a pass your guard,
if you fuck up, you'll see high level
guys own the UFC in the first round,
the do somebody triangles, which
is, it's always crazy me, is all,
they'll be losing the fight and they'd
be like second round, third round,
and they do body triangles. [inaudible]
tobacco from the guard, from the guard,
from the guards, weird from the band.
Same from the back is going to happen.
In other words, you know you're losing
the fight, right? It's so critical.
It's like stolen and you're taking
away two of your weapons anyway,
but really he's losing
the fight and he's like,
and this shit's looking really
bad. I'm on my back. I'm very,
I'm not very good on my back.
I'm not going to let it get worse.
I'm going to put on a triangle.
That's what they're thinking.
I'm not going to let it get any worse.
It's getting really bad right now.
Rather survive with the guy and the guard.
Then have the guy pass a mountain and
then really take them out to see loved
guy's tough man. Let's see if he comes on
to third round. He said just hit Damien.
Maia would a hard fucking leg kick
I think. Stop forgetting six three.
What the hell happened there?
Wow.
It's just tough feedback. Damien
Maia is uh, he's tired man.
He exerted a lot of energy
trying to finish in that side and I think
the one 70 cuts tough form and we've
seen them have us. Uh, what's your
walk around 200 pounds or something?
He's a big boy. Yeah, he
really love, love. Just nailed.
Why walks one 90? He's tired. He's tired.
Holy Shit. No doubt y'all gloves trying
to wear him out. That's why too. Wow.
He's pushing them right now. Yaka
level looks way more. Way more fresh.
You got to get the first two rounds of
Damien. Oh no doubt. He has to finish.
He's going to lose this fight.
If he just asked you leg kicks though.
He hit him with three hard
leg kicks in this round.
Okay,
let's see if he can land some
strikes is kind of interesting, man.
I love shifts. You know, that's
what makes fight so interesting.
When you see a guy pull,
pull victory out of the jaws of defeat,
figure out a way to get out of a hole
like you thought homeboys just can get
dominated that those get finished in
the first round. Yeah, look at him.
Here he is and the third.
Okay,
and Damien Maia can't touch him
and he hits him again. Boom.
Know Maya's these hurt dude.
I got my leg massage today and I
almost tapped out getting a massage.
I a woman on your idea of a
guide on the side of your leg.
My calves on a lady who knows how
to use her elbows. Right. She's,
she's really knowledgeable,
really knowledgeable in to Damien.
Maia is getting fucked up with
his leg and eat up. I mean,
I don't know how many of these
he's going to be able to do what?
He can't feel them right now,
but it's definitely taken a toll on,
but you really can't feel him. You won't
be able to walk tomorrow. I bet. Yeah.
I think you're probably right.
Look at this time again son.
Oh my God. This is going to
win him the fight for sure.
No doubt he's not getting up.
The only way this guy's ever getting out
of this position of Zip Maya goes for
an arm bar.
And why would he go for an arm bar if
he's dominated the first two rounds?
If he's this tired, he's tired. No,
but I feel like in that first round he
should've went for something man. Yeah.
I got an arm bar from here.
I mean by the web transition methodically.
I'm out. Yup. Well why isn't he
doing it? Because he doesn't want to.
He wants to right now to just punch
this guy cause he's tired too hard cause
there are a,
or if he just doesn't mean he wants to
be able to get enough energy for a burst
and he wants to be able
to get into big issue.
Lori's reasonably convinced that he's
going to be able to finish it. Right.
You know,
he just doesn't want to exert everything
and wind up in the bottom getting
grounded,
pounded when the bell wants out.
Cause that's what happened in
that one round. Right. He got,
he got reversed and you know, that's
forgot like that. That fucking sucks. No,
he doesn't want to feel that he's
a dominant ground fighter. That's,
that's a terrible feeling that he fucked
up and wound up on the bottom that it
could have cost him the round. You
know, that kind of feeling. But look,
his mount is like a goddamn
building on your chest. So good.
So good. I love seeing it, man. I
know some people at home are like, oh,
this is so boring.
I literally,
there's nothing more I like to see when
you see a guy who a mount is that God is,
you can't see what he's doing. Like he
just looks like you look at his feet.
It looks like he controls when he goes
to explode, he takes one of them away.
It's also is his balance and his position.
It's what it is,
is a lot of it is on knowledge of Jujitsu
first knowing what to do in any given
circumstance and then thousands of hours.
I thought that guy just tapped.
What did he just do?
It really is just like a wild bull.
Exact same thing. The same muscles you
see. You see guys lose mount all the time.
USC All the time, but world class
black belts like Damien Maia,
they have that next level type mouse
got bucked off because they've been on
longer. He's been doing, he's
been in this position, you know,
since he was thousands of
hours since he was sick.
So to him this is home and you're
saying watch his feet, watch his feet.
When this guy goes to explode, he's going
to take away one of his hooks. Yeah,
look at,
look how beautifully transitions,
but no, no, no. Look,
the guy gets the half guard and boom
right into side control and he's going to
take us back again. Man.
He's got to have medicine.
He's got to do something.
Is either going to take us back
like he gave him the options.
He gave him two options. Either you
take us back right? Mount you. Yeah,
the dude's Coke [inaudible] triangle.
He's stepping over right now.
He's 20 seconds to go. Let's
see if it could pull it. Oh,
he's got both arms in though.
Man Does.
He might do it on a bar and he's going
for an arm bar. He lost the arm. Wow.
He's still trying to set it up.
Switch you still? Yeah, to look at us.
He's still spitting on him. I wish you
had done then the first round Damien Maia,
you owe me $20 the juice is running.
You ever see that video?
Oh the guys back up on his feet
kicked him right.
Oh Shit.
I was it.
Damn the Russian guys she
got it has to be frustrated.
Mounted for basically nine minutes.
The 15 minute fight.
It's fucking that guys do do it
through. So God damn good. I love it.
But I love the fact that Russian
dude made it to the end. Yup.
Very interesting stuff.
This is Steve and these dudes coming over,
man. I was talking about this with Henna.
I don't people when guys get to mount,
some people freak out like
all the fights over. It's,
it's typically not these
days because there's not,
there's not a high level Jujitsu
going on a lot of the times.
So guys get to mountain, they lose it.
They just think it's over. Cause they,
it's two guys who don't know Jujitsu and
there's a big heavy guy and mount and
he's gonna Punch his face then.
But in most cases guys are
getting out these days.
I don't think this is dangerous
to everyone thinks look,
can you just see y'all keep that Russian
guy out of the sun in please. Yeah.
What burning it starts smoking
to say you needs a spray Tan.
You see Michael Kesa and um,
and train Aldo that that last fight
I did not dude. Michael Key. Yes.
Has got a Goddamn ground game.
Holy Shit.
Turn all those obese dude cancer was
mountain cam and it was really hard for
that dude to get them off of them.
As soon as he got him down on the ground.
I mean it was just, she asked
the ring, the guy adjusting,
constantly adjusting suck.
Yes. And ultimate fighter.
I thought that guy was going to last
one second and he ends up winning it.
How about Tony Ferguson?
Did
you see that cocoon and beat the shit out?
You know what he told me?
You know what Tony told me? I don't, you
know, he's a 10th planet Purple Belt,
so we talk a lot and he comes
to Hbcu every Thursday night.
So He's a training at 10th
Planet Costa Mesa with Casey.
And it comes to rain too. I see
him. Yeah, he comes, he, yes.
He goes the range as well. He, you know,
he says, what do you think about cocoon?
I go,
my advice was I suggest shit.
I'm not going to tell a fighter of my
what to do. I'm just going to suggestion.
I said, the only way he's
going to beat you is standing.
He's fucking everybody up. He goes
after the liver, you know, cocooned. Oh,
a weird dude in his karate style
I've ever seen in the UFC. He just,
all he does is drop dudes with liver
kicks and he's fucking people up.
It worked in Japan so well that
he got into the UFC and I said,
don't fuck around with that. Take his
ass down. Tony wrestled in college.
I go take him down.
Tony's Jujitsu is insane.
It's very suited to his judges.
Transitions or sick.
I was most impressed with cocoon. Oh,
that notches. He took those punches,
but he got out of that Doris. Then I
talked to Tony afterwards. He was like,
I don't, it wasn't, he wasn't squeezing.
Right. You just want to get, I'm tired.
His heart rate up. Right, so
this is what he told me. I said,
I would take them down. Go, what do
you want it? I just don't fuck around.
Don't give them a shot. Take them
down. And he said, you know what?
I'm going to dot them up a
little bit and I think, you know,
play with them a little bit. Then I'm
going to take him down and some metal.
I said, that's what you want to do.
Go for it. I'm like, you're going to,
you're going to dance around with this
guy who's dropping fool after full with
liver shots. You're going to give
them a shot. I go, go for it.
That's how he's fucking like Conan the
barbarian. Yeah. He does exactly that.
He dots among exactly where they took
him down, owned them on the ground,
and then stood up a shock them the fucking
out with a big right hand and then he
got tagged in the first round.
It cuno tagged them cocoon.
I was one of those guys. You can get
one shot to try and find them right.
And you're not going to duplicate
that in the training room.
You get one live shot at this
dude. Honestly, I gotta be honest.
I was laughing at him. You could
go, you could get a guy. I cocooned.
There's his fighting style.
There's Saint Japan homie.
You get punched right in the face.
Tony, Tony Ferguson and Tony Ferguson.
Tony is a monster. I've been
in, I've been in the end,
the main industry since I've been getting
paid working in the MMA history since
2000 yeah,
I seen a lot of motherfuckers come and go.
I seen fighters coming to go fight
camps, come and go. Apparel, MMA,
apparel companies coming. I seen working
backstage at the UFC for eight years.
You see them come and go and
see him coming down. Seriously.
I've never met anybody like Tony Ferguson.
I never met anybody like him is he really
is like an operation 40 secret aside,
he was born to do this.
He's doing in the game.
I've never seen anybody studied
the game. Man, cat dude.
He just breaks shit down and puts,
he is learning Jujitsu
at such a rapid pace.
He's got all these transitions that him
and Casey are putting together and they
just, they come up on Thursdays and they
show me what they've been working with.
I'm like,
they're putting
insane stuff together. There's,
there's not too many guys.
I'll stop and watch spar.
Right, because I have an ego.
There's not to cause that
to me guys who you are.
Stop and watch spar, but tone.
It wouldn't. Tony spires.
I'll watch to see Jack's dudes are really,
yeah.
I like your when kick comes a
gym I can we fight to get me.
He's like too and I'm like, Oh, who
spoiled with Tony? I'm like, excellent.
I'll you're my rounds and
just watch it destroys these.
Then I'm going to dot this dude
up a little brash as a killing.
Everybody might, even if the
guys who it is, I'm going to go,
hey bro, just say, you
know, I'm going to die.
He was,
he got his back,
hit them up and one of those like
Kevin Randleman Fay door slam.
It was an epic before I die or I
die. Hey Bro, just say, you know,
can do it like that.
You're going to be like that whole,
that the new standard.
It gets knocked out by some young cause
you would think life is a fucking movie.
I want to try that out by the way,
just so everyone knows what I, the way,
when I hit 55, I'm going
on the juice. Good again.
I'm going to shave down. Go on the
juice, get a second hair trend.
They say they say that could
Pluto has a successful uh,
MMA apparel. Uh, yes. Store in Japan.
I bet people are going in there and
be like, hey bro, you think that, uh,
is there any styles? The best way to go?
It's good in Japan. He's right. Kill him.
Karuna Japan killing guys.
But it's all about levels.
Like there's dudes who were killing guys
in other organizations and then they
get into the UFC and you
realize that your friend,
and you look really good when
you're fighting B level fighters.
But when you get in there with an a level
fighter, you're going to get fucked up.
You got to have all your fucking
t's crossed, all your I's dotted.
And some guys just don't.
And when your hands are down by your Dick
and you moving around like you're in a
karate movie, you're really,
you don't have to, you know,
you have a unique thing you're doing.
And it was super,
literally my brothers call me, we
were laughing, we laughed at him.
He tagged Tony in the first [inaudible].
That's what I'm saying for Tony,
it's such a dangerous fight because you
only get one life shot at then and the
dude hits hard as hell.
He does.
So it's like so you better bring your a
game or you can get drunk. But Tony was,
once Tony got comfortable,
Tony started lighting them up and once
you figured out that stance like, oh,
this is in the style of really done.
That's when I hit that swim move
off the back, got him into spider.
Spiderweb was fuck, got to see this. It's
an amazing, nice, nice. How long did,
how long ago? I really see he
switched around it first of Oh,
very end of the first round. That's right.
I really wish you would have finished.
I believe we're going to see Tony Ferguson
versus like Anthony Pettis and Ben
Henderson. Gilbert Melendez. I
think he's that fucking good.
He's a lot bigger than those too and
his though at the rate he's getting his
Jujitsu. I mean his Jitsu
is like, do you guys roll?
Did you teach Casey and all the attention
to what the fuck are you saying?
Earlier I was explaining with the
Tony [inaudible] every Thursday I was
explaining you weren't paying
attention to right now Brian.
He was waiting as well. Chuck
Ladell. That's what I was
watching, waiting for his,
his time to talk.
Chuck Chuck Norris right there.
He's the real chuck Norris
Dude. Great. A great commercial
and he's wearing toenail polish
the whole time. Oh, fantastic
test.
That was like a zone.
The dos Equis most interesting
man on the highest level.
That was interesting when you're
talking about levels though,
and when you get to the higher level,
shop.in fundamentals,
fundamentals where everything
was not impressed with the
Chuck Norris Commercial.
Brendan Schaub duck breast,
you didn't like that commercial.
Get bigger than that.
It was like the biggest,
you can get that kid, but that's
not what it's all about. He's like,
that shit is ridiculous.
We're going to give you $1 million.
We got this concept for this commercial.
You wouldn't be trying to
argue with the director.
You would just fucking dad
be doing some bull shit.
I be fucking [inaudible].
I don't have a problem.
It all because it's so unrealistic,
you know,
slamming your head into a wrecking ball.
It's so over the top. You get the point.
Yeah. The car stops in the midair and he
just steps out kind of like, you know,
you got your shorts branding up real dog.
That'd be dope.
With a silhouette of a real dog.
I thought about getting a guy real
doll and using them as a Jujitsu dummy.
I'm like, what would be a better thing
to use? But you'd have to explain.
Do you have to call it factory?
I don't want to know.
[inaudible] Dick [inaudible]
additional income.
You rent it out. But guys want to
give you just cause you owned it,
it was your real dot. Now,
$10,000. Just a session.
Find my DNA cash.
You call back and you go, I one hall.
But that's where I draw the line.
Just one off.
If a dude let me give you $1 million
to borrow your cash, you would do it.
What fucker guy and hard to [inaudible].
You kidding me? A mill. What are you
going to do? I'll take some value.
That's not what I was
asking. You didn't. Uh,
he was saying if someone used your
real doll would, if someone said,
if he had a real doll,
a male one,
and some guy gay offered him $1 million to
bone it. Oh, this is the piece. Hold on.
Turn the volume up on this.
Jamie. I want to hear.
This is a piece on the
alieve bag routine off dude,
who's whose names are harder to remember?
The Russians or the Japanese?
Which ones? I think it's even
as a kid is such a beast. Yeah,
he's gonna Fight Demetrius Mighty
Mouse Johnson though.
Dude Johnson some next level shit.
But he's training with John Dodson in
that picture. They just showed them. Yeah,
he trains at Jackson's, right?
Yeah. He's won for 11 straight.
He's the best little Russian. Oh, he's a
man. He's a beast. He's a legit contender.
No doubt.
But I think if you want to talk about
number one pound for pound guys to meet
you. Gotta you gotta fucking include
this guy. No one's including them.
I include them in every list.
All I hear is John Jones,
who spectacular Joe say Aldo,
who's amazing,
but you've got to include this
dude in your pound for pound list.
He does everything perfect. He's
fucking takedowns are lightening fast.
His submissions, he knocked out Benevidez
with one punch. He's, he's wicked bro.
He finished fucking Baraga in a war of
four round war and then he finishes him
with an arm bar. He's the most
well rounded fighter in the sport.
He's the most dust. Everything
black belt level. Yes.
Everything black belt level and his
technique and everything is flawless.
Everything is by the book. There's
no wasted energy, you know?
But Bagua teen off is a fucking
beast, man. He's a big dude.
He's strong as shit for 125 pounds too.
I mean,
I don't know what he weighs
when he actually gets into
that octagon at that boom.
I feel like the little guys are way more
happier to get in the octagon and fight.
Right. Well thanks. So you
think they're more happy? Yeah.
Were they finally get one of
the Hindu decision you to death?
You know what I'm saying?
These little guys,
chances you getting finished aren't
very good really. You? You're amazing.
He is not.
He knocked out morale.
I mean he submitted Moraga with an arm
bar and saying it's different overall.
I gotta agree with Brenden [inaudible]
smaller guys and those guys.
And you can get knocked out with a jab
if you're a heavy heavyweight division.
Much nicer. I know what you're saying.
I feel you. I mean, I can I get,
can I get check out that card though?
I was going to say Rory Macdonald,
Tyron Woodley, I can't wait. Craziness.
Are you nuts? That fights craziness.
Andre Alaska Brennan and John Tyron
Woodley down 14 number of how big.
It can get a lot shorter than uh,
then. Then, um, who's like
a big Demetrius Johnson.
He's like a big Demetrius Johnson
without Jujitsu Woodley. Woodley,
strays. Wrestling's explosive.
But he said one what sky
Tyrone Woodley is getting better
every fight and he's going to,
he's definitely gonna mix
it up with all the top guys.
I know you don't make calls on this iron
zinc, you have to put your money on one.
One guy in that fight. Right.
On what? And Rory Macdonald,
I would never put money on this. Saved if
I, if I would not put money on a fight,
would be totally private.
I would never admit who I'd bet on,
but I will tell you this
possible scenarios of that
fight with Rory Mcdonald is
very skillful and he's very good at
using angles and footwork and he's got a
very educated jab and if you're
not used to that jab you take,
you take a couple of them in the face
like Jake Ellenberger is and you go into a
defensive shell cause you're like, okay,
this guy is tuning me up with his jazz.
You can do a whole night. Yeah. And
every time I closed the distance,
his jab is wicked, his footwork
is wicked and moves very well.
And if you get him on the
ground is no god damn.
Pick what is no goddamn picnic
at Pickwick. Pickwick. His,
his guard is very good.
It's very good offensively.
Defensively he's got wicked butterfly
guards. He keeps your hips elevated.
He's fucking good man.
Real good.
The real question with that guy and
that fight is can he get past that first
storm? Cause Woodley's first
dorm is a motherfucker. It's
like a man versus a boy.
It's like he's, he's so God damn,
physically strong and fast and skilled.
On top of that, you know he, he
runs a weird race. That race of the,
the cutting extreme cut of weight,
extreme muscle density for 170 pounds.
But somebody had a real good point
about it on the underground though.
They were like, yeah, that cost him,
but would he be a better
fighter if he didn't have that?
That's the question you can't really
answer because he's got very special
abilities because of that build. He could
have been a leaner guy if he chose to,
if he chose to not lift weights.
If you chose to not eat as much.
If he chose to do more cardio,
he could probably get smaller.
But would he be better as a fighter?
That's an interesting because he presents
a lot of unique problems because the
fact that he's so God
damn physically strong,
85 if you stayed at 85 to [inaudible]
70 [inaudible] 85 he's too small.
He's too short.
Well,
I think that comes back to what I
talked about with Tim Kennedy too,
which is there should be more
fucking weight classes, period.
There should one f one seven
eight one 85 his god damn crazy.
Oh, that's crazy. Crazy. I was,
fuck we doing any more weight classes?
I think it's fine.
I mean you just got to find
your spot and you can't
until you too diluted
until you're 235 pounds.
Lavar Johnson's roid it up
at two 65 again. You guys,
you guys are crazy. Well, he's an animal.
No,
I disagree with Mr Bravo.
I don't think we need to grow. I think
we did a two 25 there's already a lot of,
you have to like,
we can barely keep up with the UFC now.
Like you're going to add another way.
That's for the APP.
More chick weights before you add
more guy or chick. Chick chick.
Awesome. Are you kidding?
I agree. I agree.
It's fascinating watching women
with good technique fight.
When there's one Ronda Rousey,
there's a cup.
Just legit black belt. Right? Look,
aside about Cyborg, Cyborg, Cyborg.
Whoa, whoa. Rhonda. Hold about.
We're talking about the UFC.
I'm not talking of
these bullshit amateurs.
We're getting knocked out and boy tie
events on freaking access TV nine I'm
talking about,
I'm talking about Seibel.
She's not coming to the UFC and there's
no one 45 category and you can't,
she's going to 35, dude. She's going to
have to Rhonda, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. No,
you're good. You're good. No,
she can come after Rhonda.
You're going to have to pass a lot of
steroid tests and no one's trying to see
that bullshit. Well, I
mean you're, I favor.
Might as well get a Tan and jump
in there and get a boob job.
You know what I'm saying?
What are we doing,
Ron with a blue Ronda
versus Cyborg is going to be the
biggest MMA fight and fucking history.
Everyone's, everyone's going to
want to watch it. Yeah. Every,
every element that's going.
Plus their grandmas and their aunts
and their little girl cousins,
they're all going to watch that one. Do
you remember when, when, uh, Cyborg fod.
Gina de that odd. The audience that the
screen sound like a Beatles concert.
Here's the pro whole different animal
she was cycling versus Rhonda is going to
be the biggest fight ever. Trust
a Cyborg. He has some work to do.
There's a bunch of problems is going
to happen. She's been testing side one.
I just want to see the fight. That's the
great. Rhonda is fucking everybody up.
She needs some competition and Cyborg
is very confident. She wants her.
That makes a great store. She
wants Mr upstairs. She wants,
it's like playing grab ass in the
minor league. Tell you us she wants to.
That's the payday. If I'm a girl,
of course. Of course. That's
you think there's an
issue. If a, if a woman is,
let's say she was really taking
male steroids, I don't know.
She tested positive give accident.
She says it was something
very different.
Very different.
Very different ones to a man
taking a testosterone supplement.
When he takes his body has testosterone.
A man's supposed to have testosterone.
When a woman takes testosterone,
there's physiological changes there that
are first. Cyborg has male genitalia.
No, it's irreversible. They
get stronger, they get thicker.
They get higher bone density to get wider.
Their face structure changes, their,
their musculature changes.
I know all that.
I know that and I know just like Drago.
Everybody knew Drago was on roids
but they still wanted rocky for,
you know what I mean? Like
I had a script. Good point.
You're saying it's bad
for this or whatever.
I think it's bad for the weekend and
how are we going to pretend that like a
large percentage of, I mean what
are we supposed to do on the show?
A large percentage of these
fighters are on some ships.
Don't you think there's a difference
between a guy taking guy stuff in a girl
taking guy stuff? You know what
else taking male hormones. She's,
she's changing her gender.
You are probably correct.
I'm not even thinking about that shit.
I'm thinking about, I would love to see.
I want to, I want to see Drago
versus rocky. I agreed on these.
Rocky Drago is Cybil.
I agree with you and I agree with shop.
I agree with Shab as an athlete.
I think Rhonda shouldn't have to deal
with someone who may or may not have
altered their body in a way that's
irreversible and gives them an advantage.
I'm obviously no doctor,
so I don't know if that's the case,
but what I've read is that there's,
they've showed permanent results,
like permanent changes to people
who've done things like this.
But if Cyborg can suck
down 35 that'd be a very,
very tough weight cut. Wait, God. Yeah,
she's very, I mean, she's very big, so,
so it might even the score and that. Now
let me ask you something now of someone,
a woman who,
uh,
it grows up doing vigorous
exercise and gets into judo,
judo to the point she goes to
the Olympics while she's growing,
does all that exercise do something
to increase your testosterone?
It's a very good question. I don't know.
Does it? It's a very good question.
I would say it's not artificial
though. No, still. Yes, yes.
I know what you're saying. And of
course, Cyborg, suspicious sideboards,
a monster. Cyborgs mark, very
skilled for sure. No doubt.
100% no, she's very skilled. Black.
I think she's a black man on the
ground. Correct? Jujitsu Brown.
She's a monster.
Hell of a fighter.
I'm just saying there's certain things
that need to happen as a fan, as a fan.
Do you want to see that? I don't want
to see it. Can I get some color on this?
That's fine. Just not a fan of uh,
sideboards. Once you fight other girls.
It's hard for me to watch like when she
fought Gina Brown Cyborg as a brown belt.
No, I know. It just looks like
two different levels in there.
You know what I'm saying?
It looks like almost like a strong
ass girl versus a normal girl. Con.
I don't like to see her
just bullying him around.
But Rhonda as strong as fuck
I think is technique though.
Strong road there plenty of
times. Meat, chicken, strong.
She's pretty strong for sure.
But Sarah McMahon was more strong.
Look what happened to her.
Yeah. You know what I'm saying?
Can I get some comps saying I want to
satisfy cyborgs number father girl,
who's stronger than Rhonda has. That's
what I'm saying did, but she just joined.
She destroys them with technique. I
want to see it. That would be awesome.
I think everyone, everybody wants
to see that. Are you kidding?
That's where I sat for me. I don't want
to see it. I don't care for it. Yeah,
we'll look. I see both of your points
of view. I'm just wanting to see it.
I want to see it as a fan.
But I'd rather watch Meesha and
Ronda fight nine times about that.
If the doctors are correct,
if the doctors,
if the doctors are correct and
anything that she did take, you know,
it gives her a permanent advantages.
How crazy would it be? A volunteer.
That would be amazing. Right?
It comes on real weird.
I think she beats her to cyber has a
real weird discussion. I agree. But when,
when you allowed to do that, like what
are you allowed to do to your body?
And I think, oh no, he caught him
behind the ear. That was a big shot.
This dude is, this is a gut dash. Yeah.
These guys were revved up. Good. Hit.
Go off. Yeah. Good half guard there. Um,
it's an interesting conversation Eddie,
cause I see your point of
view as a fan and Brendan,
I see what you're saying too. I mean,
and I see both of them because as a fan,
if it was on fuck for sure.
Um, I would call that fight.
I would hope there'd be a pay per view
fight and I would get to call it because
obviously you would, I'm, I'm just
saying Cyborg fan me to listen. I'm,
I'm sure I'm gonna get some hate for this.
There's no disrespect to Cyborg.
However,
I just don't like to see here bullied
these little girls that Rhonda Rhonda
problem. There's no problem. Did you see
her kickboxing bout Dorina bars? Yes,
I did. Great. She got knocked out. Well
she got dropped. Mars is a bad bitch.
You're well people, they like go
cyborg glass and she fought a very,
very high level striker in her
world in kickboxing, Muay Thai,
lost goods like a post nine, like, Hey,
I'm just in here. Just get for sure. Yeah,
she know. She knows sideboards a month.
Just practicing. It was, it was great.
I don't know, man. Look. It's
interesting man. I would like to see it.
It's interesting. It's very
interesting. But you know the, the,
there's a real discussion.
How about what people should be able to
get away with and not get away with far
they take,
what do you think about Gabby Garcia
fight and I'm just fighting and MMA.
Gabby Garcia used to be a very heavy,
she used to be a gigantic shoot yet
to check six foot four 200 gigantic,
250 pounds. She's like a giant
dude, like a six foot three,
six foot four. He's
giant. And she would cry.
She would just enter
absolute cause that was,
no one ever goes to absolute and there's
going to be an opposite and she just
smashes everybody.
I was watched,
I ran into her Abu Dhabi
and Beijing. I didn't, she,
I don't think he speaks any English so
we were like in the elevator together and
match.
It was like a giant mafioso hit man
like right next to me going home and she
just smashes everybody.
But that was a Russian leg lock check on
the other side about one 80 and she was
leg lock in the shit out of everybody on
the other side of the bracket and I go,
Oh shit,
this might,
this might be trouble for Gabby who
knocked this gap was just smothering
everybody and they met I think
in the finals or the semifinals.
Gabby just fucked a steroid or
Russian chick was sad.
She was sitting on the side by
herself, by herself. But Gabby,
since then, she decided to get in
the best shape of her. God Damn Luck.
She's shot ready.
She looks like frank shamrock.
She lost all that weight.
She's actually working on a machine.
That's a good question.
What does Gabby Garcia
fights way fighting in Japan?
In Japan. They don't care. They
don't bring a little chat box guys.
Try not to talk over each other.
My bad. Sorry. Both of you just,
I agree, but it's super hard to listen
to what people are complaining about.
Cox. No, no, no, no. Let's
call these fights. I slow down.
Nothing wrong with calling shredded shot.
That's her now.
I wish you would,
you would've found a picture of her fat
before she tested positive for fertility
drug. I Dunno what the fuck did that,
but it's not of fertility. Drugs do that.
Gimme Fabric Garcia test positive for
fertility drugs stripped of her 2013
world's title one's
Brazilian Jujitsu powerhouse.
Gabby Garcia failed a
drug test from the IB.
J E F F 2013 worlds has
been stripped of her metals,
but it might not be what you think.
Hmm.
Test Pause for being jack
for a fertility drug.
Wonder would a fertility drug
would do for you dude drugs,
I dunno man. For like dragon fertility
or something. She doesn't have gargoyles.
Can you imagine having a kid with her?
I would like to impregnate her and
see what happens is a, that is a,
you know what I mean? Just as
an experiment, I'll, I'll just,
I'll pay some child support. But
true. That's phenomenal. That is.
Look at that bottom. Come on. Gabby
is in tremendous. So she goes,
she's going to fight pitches.
God,
so you're talking about Cyborg
Cyborg turns 10 Brian's turned on.
I'm a little turned off.
I'm actually producing estrogen.
Look at her body fucking bleaks.
Theirs are better than mine.
The greatest fight of all time.
You're so hilarious.
It's going to be Rhonda versus
Rhonda.
You haven't seen him lately.
I'm sure there I haven't.
You ever seen me in that outfit,
dude,
so before you actually do
me in that outfit and I'll,
and see how I look compared to
that. Wow. Come on. Jump into MMA.
She's fighting on the same card is
chrome. Gracie was. Is that what it is?
That's incredible. Wow. That's amazing.
That's nuts, man. You know what?
My hats go off to her.
Look at what great shape she's in.
She's in phenomenal shape, right?
I don't care. She's a chicken.
She's not supposed to look like that.
That's a lot of hard work right there.
That's a serious diet and has a lot of
hard training. Your yeah. Behind you.
Like that's what she used to look
like. That's, yeah. That's incredible.
I'm looking at that. Yeah, but
it's better. Larger. Come on.
That's hard work right there.
And fertility drugs apparently.
I'd imagine there's some hormone will
help involved in that, I would imagine.
I'm not saying, Oh guys, look nice.
Remember I told you that about
that story if you got down. Yeah.
If you got down to like what is her
body? Her right there. Holy Shit.
Put that over there. Oh my
gosh. Recently she was coaching.
Morphing Vandelay big. She is
families. Vandalism. The sauce. Rice.
What is he six feet tall.
Do you think
Jack Bentley's biceps. Holy
Shit. She's bigger up dude. Yeah,
I got her while we haven't
called this fight all over.
People are gonna hate
Marcio. E. X. A. N. D. R.
E I would imagine. Zhan
dre and uh, Warley. Elvis.
Elvis, I think it's called.
Yeah, Dude. It's Alexandra here.
Like a l. E. X. Alexandra.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Is it a oh well,
they don't have it on those site.
His head is in front of his fucking
letter in his name. How stupid is that?
Oh goodness. Oh God. It's so
far that that's so John Gray,
who's the dumb Alexandra? Who's the
fucking most don't know what it says.
Who's the mommy that does that?
That's so stupid. I never did that.
And a w the UFC site.
That's so dumb. Texts Dana,
he'll get right to it and
then cover 90 seconds.
How could you cover a guy name with it?
Right? What did you run out of space?
You file.
This has been taken it to this
guy and I'm sure the guy
who designs our website,
a very nice guy you don't want
to fear is he just fucked up.
He has been taking it to got the underhook
and half wash. He goes to full guash.
They're saying they're saying chill out.
There's a freaking superstar now.
They love him. Isn't that hilarious? Yeah.
They love him. They love him in Brazil.
After all the shit he talked
about Anderson and all the
shit that the people are
so mad they wanted to fuck him up
from Brazil did. He doesn't know.
And the scenes that I saw from that,
I've only seen a couple of times.
He looks like really like
he's not nonconfrontational.
He's that Vander Vandelay get mad so bad.
She also, and as Jack Armstrong,
all American, they do on the show.
He was the hook and he started a fight
with him. He just looked like an asshole,
a chill set.
Every time he'd walk into
any room Vandelay it'd be
there with a mouth piece and
trying to fight him and chill.
It's like bro, listen behind
scenes. He's like, dude,
I'm not going to fight you every
time. This is stressful, man.
This is for the show. We're doing this
forest show. We're going to fight.
You don't have to do this every time.
Vandelay [inaudible] was not having it.
So I was on UFC tonight,
last Wednesday and chill.
We were sitting there and you just got
the text that he's fighting a chill
vittores sorry.
Fighting that
tail said it exactly how everyone
was thinking. He goes, well one guy,
you're kind of like, I can beat him.
They knew when changes. You're like,
ah shit. Yeah. Cause I mean beat doorman.
You're talking to a different game now.
South Pole. No, I mean like
tricky ass, ridiculous striking.
I said anyways,
let's be as honest as possible.
Hard as fuck to take desk to be
honest as possible here post TRT.
How is that possible?
How is it guy go from what Vito was doing?
UFC, the way he looked,
how dominant he was.
Three fights in a row knocks how Bisbing
knocks out Luke Rockhold with a wheel
kick to the head, knocks out
Henderson in the first round saying,
looks like a destroyer
on TRT the entire time.
What do you chalk that up to us
at his age? Question, but, well,
here's the big question.
How do you get off of that stuff and then
get your testosterone to a level where
you can fight? Well, when you have a, uh,
TRT exemption [inaudible] I think
maybe they can be on TRT 24,
seven and they don't have to worry
about shit that got the exemption.
But now that they're being
stricter, no, you don't understand.
There's no exemptions. No,
there was a lot. There's,
they're done. There's no, no,
I know, I know. No, no, no. I know.
I know. No, no, no. They're done.
Now that they're done,
does it make the guys go back to the
old school way and just say, okay,
we've got a cycle and it's
going to be all black? Yeah,
it's cause we already know about the
stricter rules and steroids and then get
Vanair lays on him. He just got hot blue.
We don't know. No, he didn't get popped.
He just refused to take his
test. We don't know. He,
they came to office or Dick
came to his gym and they
said, you know, they,
they need a random drug test from him.
And he was like,
you don't have any identification.
Who are you? I don't,
I need to get my lawyer to look at this.
And he said that he always submits his
drug results and submits his blood tests
at the proper time. If you've got
to give the guys fair day in court,
I know what you're saying for that.
Now you can, that's not a good exam.
Weirdo could show up and pretend that
he's some fucking UFC representative or a
Nevada state athletic
commission representative with
no id or no, uh, you know,
no credential example.
But, uh, nonetheless, uh,
does that,
do MMA fighters?
Do UFC fighters get tested more
often than football players do that?
Yes,
we can test it without questioning.
Let's get tested usually once a year
unless you fail it and then you get put
into a program or you're randomly tested
throughout the season a few months
before. I can help you out
with this. It's real simple.
Combat Sport athletes in general get
tested more than any other sport.
UFC fighters get tested more
than any other combat athletes.
It was just until recently that
they started testing drugs,
a drug testing boxers and it was a lot
of it is Floyd Mayweather sand a lot of
shit about guys like um,
pack Yao.
So he submitted to these
random, you know, uh,
Olympic style drug tests, random. They
show up at your house at any time.
They take blood tests from him.
He submitted to those and he sorta
changing boxing because of that.
And he kept saying while he's
doing it with cleaning it up,
boxing still a lot of guys who were like
kind of perturbed about Manny Pacquiao.
That was the big rumors at patio.
Yeah, he's destroying everybody.
But look what happened.
I keep,
the guy's gone through eight God damn
weight classes and everybody's saying that
he's on steroids.
I don't know if he's on steroids,
but I know that Floyd Mayweather believed
he's on steroids and a lot of other
people believed he's on steroids.
So they just started testing
people on like super regular basis.
Can they test you shit like this,
but I'm sorry.
Shit like this where they did with what?
They caught a Alistair Overeem,
random drug tests where they
wanted to do this to, to uh,
Vandelay random drug tests.
They did it to veto random drug test and
Vito was on testosterone and that was
the reason why testosterone
got banned in the first place.
The whole thing went down when they
tested pause, when Vito tested positive,
the Vata State Athletic Commission.
After that.
Before that they were considering him for
a testosterone exemption and there was
a lot of talk whether or not he would
be up for a testosterone exemption.
But because when they tested him,
he tested positive.
They scrapped the whole testosterone
program with v toward stuff. Man,
cause you talk to him. I'm gone.
This tour. He was hurting dudes, man.
Oh Yang's eyes. Can you, can you
test for human growth hormone?
Yes you can.
But I don't think they're doing that
only through blood and it has to be like
you'd have to inject in,
they have to test like right away.
Elvis tagged him with a right
and then got off the ground.
He's got an arm and gay teens. That's
it. It's over. It's done. He's going up.
He's out. Al called Eddie. What
do you think about this? Um,
about a lot of guys don't
even go up high on the neck.
Like he didn't go high on the neck there.
He just pulled back like a regular gates.
Him.
It's okay if you've got a deep grip. No,
no, no. Deep grip is one kind of gear.
Teen Shallow Grip. That's another kind
of getting, that's more of a net crank,
shallow grave. But what he did right there
where he leaned back, I see that again.
Well, he leaned back. They'll show it in
the, in the replay. We just straight back,
right? Yeah. He leans
back there. Slept money.
Statistically when you got an arm in,
usually the right technique is to go up
high on the neck and put weight on the
neck and crushing and crushed the victim.
It's more of an angle angle
and bend them doing leg curls.
Smash.
He just pulled back like a regular duty.
But obviously he puts you to sleep. Let's
see here. Let's see. It was crazy. Yeah,
so Alvez tagging right hand.
Oh,
welcome to Queer Street on
population. You all right. So here,
look how he's doing this. He's got
it. And look, that's a good regular,
he's doing like bending.
He's betting the, yeah,
it's just a regular arm and
getting done, right? Yeah,
a little bit of that side of himself.
He's doing leg curls. He's not pulling,
he's actually bending down and don't
watch like was right and then bending that
thing and
it's a perfect good.
What he's doing with an angle is what
you would do if you were head on by going
up high in the neck.
So it all depends on what his grip was
doing to some people like to go ball and
socket some like the Pretzel Grip and all.
Depends what he's doing underneath.
Yeah.
Isn't that interesting how some guys just
have that fucking guilty and like when
you saw um,
Joseph Benevidez get that mounted
guillotine on Tim Elliot has like,
there's some dudes if they just get that
arm in there and it doesn't matter what
happens next or one way or another,
they're going to find a way to finish
that bitch off that looks like Dunkin.
I dug it out of the fucking mountains.
That is Dunkin. When Harley talk,
if you could have a Harley,
if he lives in North Carolina,
if he went back to Asheville,
where he's from, dude,
you ever been the most more beautiful
place in Asheville, North Carolina?
You ever been there?
No Dude,
we did a Raleigh and then we did raw,
were always beautiful.
But after we did Raleigh, but we're take
a drive into the mountains to Asheville.
It's like a utopian community in the
middle of the North Carolina mountains.
It's still crazy shit of all time.
I have a friend who lives up there and
he's telling me how amazing it was,
but I couldn't, I couldn't believe it
until I got there. Beautiful place.
Super Intelligent people.
It's a college town walking the streets,
people just friendly restaurants,
bars, low population,
Asheville,
North Carolina from north girl population.
This is how crazy the town is.
There's,
there's so many trippers in that
town that the farmers started putting
antifungal properties and the cows
food to make sure that they didn't grow
mushrooms on them because it's all rainy
up there and like silicide mushrooms
naturally grow on cow patties out there.
So these kids are all tweaked
on mushrooms like all the time.
So much so Caroline.
So much so that farmers started spending
their own fucking money to make sure
that they didn't have psychedelic
mushrooms growing on their cow. Shit.
You know how many,
how many times that I call the paramedics
to get these kids passed out in their
borrowings house like passed out.
I climb,
I climb big whiskey mountain on mushrooms
in Wyoming. I was hugging a rock.
I had a long conversation with a rock.
My buddy turns around and look at me,
we're hot. It is the true story.
He turns around and look and he,
I have no clothes on, just my sneakers
and he goes, where are your clothes? I go,
I don't know. We couldn't find
my clothes. I came back down.
I had asked Patty about this.
I had a blue mouth for many
blueberries and I was completely naked.
We never found my Elvis is a
bad motherfucker. Man attacked.
Yeah, he's, he's super bummed
out. Kids got some traps on them.
It's so different for
you, isn't it? You know,
and the difference between a guy like
these random dudes talk shit on the
Internet,
you know,
and the impact that has on a guy like you
who puts his whole fucking life on the
line.
What does that feel like when you,
like when you lose a fight and
then you go on Twitter and see it?
Just a bunch of people fucking with
you, man. It's not too bad anymore.
And I think from doing the
podcast stuff like that,
people get a sense of my personality and
these things. I was just like this Dick,
like cocky Dick, you know? But,
but doing podcasts and doing more
interviews and getting out there,
I get to show a little bit of personality.
But marijuana when I lost to, uh,
I think,
uh,
Rothwell one time when I've lost a
Rothwell my Twitter was so negative,
it was insane. And then before I
was gonna Fight Lavard Johnson,
huge fight in my career. Right.
You lose that one. You know,
who knows what happened to tour
playing grab ass can $500. So, um,
you know,
before that one I stayed off social media.
I'd make a post by went reading anything
they post, don't read anything good.
And then, uh, even even
before the [inaudible],
it started to get a little bad.
The week of the fight.
I don't look at social media at all.
I make a post and I don't look at it
at smart, but, but now man out there,
there is, but I gotta be honest now
it's like I got a lot of support.
It's really cool man. Well,
when you do a podcast,
people get to know who the fuck you
really are. It's so easy to write you off.
You're confident. Big
looking at a big hog. Yeah.
See you
big old dude. That guy. I want him to
suck. I wanted it to be an asshole.
There's a lot of dudes that
I read on the underground.
I don't know if you go on the underground,
but a lot of dudes love you now because
of your podcast and because of the
podcast you guys did with us.
The last one you did. They said,
we really got to see who he is. They
were like, you guys have great chemistry.
It's all right. It's funny. Brandon is
Brent. Brendan had you laughing harder?
I've ever seen your laugh.
I wish.
I wish he could tell
all the stories I wish.
I wish I could tell him. I'll tell
you what, ladies and gentlemen,
we're going to go get some steak after
this podcast and you're going to miss the
best podcast.
I got some new shit.
They do. I ever, oh, we're
going to eat some meat.
You guys are the only ones I can
tell the stories. That's okay.
We're on the Internet. 20
minute face, half black. If you
and your is, uh, ethnic, uh, nope. So
my mom was born and raised in England.
Straight white chick. And what's your
dad? And then my dad's German, Italian.
French. His Dad couldn't look
more native American by the way.
Couldn't look more native American. A lot
of Italians that are basically monkeys.
Yeah, that's what it is. Shop guys.
Some of that Italian [inaudible] some
big Italian dinner from the east coast.
10 Damn Alvarez is a beast.
And so what was your,
he played pro football's,
yeah, call Jerome. Jesus law.
I played four years,
four years at University of Colorado and
then a short stint with buffalo bills.
They keep showing this one
right hand over and over again.
But that was very loud. Yeah. Tony
Gonzalez. Since you didn't miss that.
Tony gets off of in this big, Aaron
Hernandez. Are you working on the book?
Look more like bring up our Aaron
Hernandez and take a look at [inaudible].
I know Pete. Hola. Hannah's.
Oh, okay. That's a white dot.
I was in, uh, I was in Ralph's
and these guys behind me, I like,
I can hear him on the cell phone too.
Black guys,
like now I'm looking at this mother
fucker right now. No, he posted bail son.
I'm looking at right now.
I'm like, I turned out like
it's Aaron fucking her name.
Dez. I'm like, Bro,
it's not him so much like him to bring
him up and then when I jumped in my
Prius, Nah, that ain't him.
My first black belt. Denny percopo six
exact little bit. Brandon, by the way,
look, look at this. Wait, hold on. Hey,
that's a good looking murderer though.
Let's be honest, Danny. I find Danny,
he looks more like a big Denny.
He has a Greek look like
you could be a Greek statue,
but there are other pictures where
he looks a lot more like Aaron. No,
he doesn't look like Eric. I'm sorry.
Sorry. I, you know what I get? Oh No, no,
he does. Eddie. That's just a bad image.
Just go images on Denny.
Come on.
Come on dude. I rolled with him in
San Francisco, uh, like a month ago.
I told him to stay away from big guys.
You know he was dope man.
Now he was dope. No, you so
much fun to roll. Yeah, no,
he's awesome. All right. I,
we'll go back to Aaron Hernandez and he
does the 10th planet in San Francisco
Right before he runs. Yeah, he came
down to empowers with that. Tarek,
let's get some pictures of
a, Oh, hey, there he is.
[inaudible] you guys could
definitely be related.
How crazy this dude is in the NFL
and shot allegedly three people.
Three people is 24. He's
24. He shot two people.
James Gang related shit.
What?
He's in the pros and he's an,
again,
the best tight ends on the
Patriots on the one that SBC bats.
He signed a 42 wait a minute.
$42 million deal.
Did he grow up in La Right now?
Connecticut,
Connecticut. There's a Mexican gangs and
Connecticut reportedly having Oh nuts.
Not Mexicans. Puerto Rican having a
tough time paying his defense team.
They don't give a fuck. That's
sucking you dry cow. They don't care.
They don't give a fuck.
How much money does he have?
You know I heard he has a big old
hug by the way. A big old hog.
Dang.
What are you thinking though?
Don't you wish you could talk to like
your 24 millions in the bank? I mean,
pride was going to be one of the best
times ever in the NFL. If freak man,
freak out. Look at this. Look at this.
Ridiculous. It got busted selling weed.
He was running back for the
Cleveland browns. Look at that.
A portion of his 12 point $5 million
bonus was supposed to be guaranteed to
Hernandez when he signed a contract
extension in 2012 is in dispute son,
and it's one point $3 million home is
a subject of a restraining order there.
Present prevents him from selling it or
using it for anything other than paying
a future judgment in a civil lawsuit
filed by the family of one of the men that
he's accused of killing. This dude is
accused of killing three fucking peep.
POW bullets. Just how did it go
down? Is that a cloud or no, no.
The one he just got indicted on is he
pulled up there saying he pulled up in a
SUV, just shot up the
SUV, killed two dudes.
And this is before he
shot this other dude.
They only found out that he did it after
he got busted for killing this other
dude. And they're saying
he killed the other dude.
Cause that dude knew stuff
about another murder he did.
And so then all these other witnesses
that you got, well you kill one person.
He's like, well, you know
something that's a to more people.
You're a murderer. Good
football player, handsome dude.
[inaudible]
are handsome dude and he's only
24 that's what's crazy. You know,
when you take a dude who's a big super
athlete and he's living in some sort of a
bad situation and he's just fucking,
just a huge,
just aggressive savage dude and that's
why he's so God damn good at football.
And then you expect them to keep his
shit together because he got an NFL
contract.
There's $25 million know you're from the
hood and you bring all your entourage
with you that's going to
work out gray. Oh Geez. No,
we're here on the phone, the
bottom now, the whole team.
And they just, they also want to prove
that they're still a jet. You know,
they're always trying to prove
like they're still tough. Like, Oh,
I'm not out the hood. There's still hood.
Maybe he wanted out trying to get out,
but he had done so much shit that
there was still some unknowns,
but he probably didn't want to do it.
You know what? I'm blowing up now.
I got to fucking kill this dude.
He's going to fucking ruin all guys
got killed him to save his career.
That's what you say. I believe him. I
don't know why, but I
do, but I don't know why,
but I do believe I've got a
feeling Aaron got soft dog,
soft change Sun people tell
me that you've changed.
Oh Shit, I've changed. Yeah.
Yeah. Hell yeah. I've changed
it. Oh, since 10th grade.
Oh really? Yeah. I've changed. I'm
rich as shit and I fight in UFC.
I've changed 100% and I'm like,
Shit, I'm not doing all right. I like
that old brand here that DOL can outside.
Do you have seen
some shit possible sponsors? You don't
understand how much the heavyweight makes?
You know what I want? Apollo was
complaining about that recently,
although he was complaining
about [inaudible] pay.
The difference in pay between
the heavyweights and the
lighter well have people,
I mean heavyweights run when you
get like 55 will show what's up.
This is not my new contracts.
Will is the last,
the oldest one I was
on the ultimate fighter
Mirko Cro cop for 10 and 10 like this.
Okay,
so you didn't make that much money before,
but now you're many.
We got here by spots,
got here and he's helicopter.
That's all he metafarm they got here on a,
on a wings of a peg.
Horseback can't as his actual numbers.
So on the podcast I refuse,
I refuse to allow it because you're asking
him a question that he might not want
to answer and you saying it live
and if you do that, like, you know,
you're not giving them a chance
to say like, I don't like,
I don't like to talk about that shit.
How much does UFC pay you? Exactly.
That's what I'm saying.
Damn your quick as fuck.
That was a serious question. Look at
Gilbert Melendez doing a little, uh,
Gilbert's doing good. Awesome. I
love that comment. Tim Kenny's.
Here's all jacked up.
Give him a Gnocchi before he got on there.
He did a great job on my fight.
He's in the 1950.
[inaudible] grapple can eat by the way,
is a close here.
Do a great job at minimum wage. Gay.
Where's Karen? Where's the boy club?
And Glover did good too.
Although he did fuck up a few told hold.
He could use a couple of,
what do you mean? Well,
I just mean like you could use it like
pause, like pause, hold, talk too much.
No, no. He can eat. He
needs a couple more reps.
It dude commentate. It's
tough. It's super tough.
Everyone thinks they can compensate
because they could talk shit while they
watched the UFC.
You know when they're drunk and they're
comfortable when the camera's in front
of you. Sanely tough. Can you be
yourself when the pressure's on? Shit,
anybody can catch up.
God Damn football high school
wide receivers have great hands.
But the difference between a high school
football player and a pro football flat
player, can you hold on to that bar when
there's pressure? That's the difference.
Do it under pressure.
What?
The other thing I can't might've heard
them a little bit is he's an ex Kenny
Florian who does it for? Yes,
Kenny was cool and there was a,
there was a couple things
that Jeff had wrong.
He thought it was setting him up
for a triangle the whole time,
like in the beginning and never
thinking about a triangle.
So he kind of fucked up there.
But overall I thought Jeff did a great
job for his first show every doing color.
Damn. You gotta just didn't get to
bring in your game. Totally. Yeah,
and he was on his own moves. He was
honest. When I wrote for the vaporizer,
he says,
I like to consider myself an expert in
Jujitsu and I'm confused right now. Kenny.
He said that he goes, what
is going on here? It's crazy.
People were doing tutorials
of the vaporizer the next
day, the next week wrong.
They had no idea what they were doing.
They thought you were talking about
and then the move at the very end,
I don't know. I'm not, I'm not qualified,
but I have to say you were doing
stuff and Joe is screaming cause he,
he saw you were getting positioned but
I have no idea that you had position
before you did it. And it was, Joe
knew what I was doing the whole time.
I knew I was going bananas.
As soon as Eddie Bravo gets a lock down,
everybody got crazy crazy when you went
from quarter guard locked. That is crazy.
And I got crazy when the Hoya got
the under hook, people wouldn't,
all the Gracies called Ya cause for six
minutes he was fighting for the underdog.
He finally gets it and they fucking
make noise for the under hook. Yeah. But
he didn't have, he
didn't have, by the way,
for the record and from my vantage point,
he never even was in the,
in the game with you. But I'll do over
due respect of course toilet. But, but um,
did you get,
did you get acknowledged for that from
the Gracie camper or how did that work?
You didn't pay attention?
I'll, I'll answer it because it's
difficult for him to answer. Yeah.
It was embarrassing.
There was there their portrayal of the
actual events where it was embarrassing.
It's like a cover up government cover up,
embarrassed for them for all of them.
That and not one of them did an accurate
assessment of it post fight until they
experience criticism.
Okay.
When the experience criticism then people
started giving him credit for being
loyal for, no, no, no, no, no.
They were being ridiculous and biased
and it was sad as a someone who's a huge
fan of the Gracies and a
huge fan of Jujitsu and um,
in massively in debt, my own personal
life for what their family's accomplished,
I'm in debt to all the Gracies
Elio, Gracie without a doubt, his,
his accomplishments and his,
his art changed my life because
it changed Eddie's life.
Eddie's life changed my life.
John Jacques Machado,
his life who changed Eddie's life.
I mean,
all of us are directly chained back
to Elios work that said, their,
their depiction of that
fight was an embarrassment.
It was an embarrassment to the greatest
martial arts family of all time.
Like they weren't accurate in
their assessment of what happened.
What happened was horrible or didn't
know what to do with at his game.
He got wrapped up,
he got,
he got swept on multiple occasions and
he got threatened twice and he got his
knee fucked up.
His knee popped in a crazy position.
Most people on the planet
would attempt to that.
Most people boiler decided not to tap
to it and they also agreed to ridiculous
rules or they never,
they never addressed the fact that the
only reason why he's able to survive was
he was allowed to grab Eddie's clothes,
but Eddie wasn't allowed to
grab his clothes. It was,
there were the most ridiculous rules.
Those rules were an embarrassment.
I was embarrassed by those
because you tried to change it.
They threatened you. They
were like, no, no, no.
You have to wear the pants if you don't
wear the pants were pulling out. He the,
the deal was Eddie wears the pants
and he can grab addies pants,
but Eddie crank grab his shorts.
It's ridiculous.
That doesn't make any sense that
someone who's fighting scared.
So Eddie agreed to that.
Anyway, goes in there,
still dominates a fight in the one
thing that's saved toilers I mean,
coilers leg was in a terrible position,
but it wasn't in the worst position.
The worst position is one step later.
And if Eddie,
if that guy wasn't able to grab Eddie's
clothes and he wasn't able to hold on
for dear life on Eddie's
the collar of his pants,
Eddie would have switched and if he
switched to putting his foot on his other
foot, if you went to that, that
the dark position. After that,
there's the vaporizer and then there's
that one step where you take the
vaporizer. Did def con 10 it's ugly.
You're leg is getting ripped apart,
your legs getting ripped apart. He's,
and I saw three I was like, that need is,
that doesn't look natural,
but that's only seven out of 10 bro.
That's seven out of 10 that the next
three steps are the ugliest shit you've
ever seen in your life and you see guys
scream in agony. God, that's horrible guy.
I hate that.
But they didn't address any of that.
When they put it on their Instagram,
their Instagram was all about how great
heuler looked and all about heuler
getting through to submission
attempts and smiling like,
what are you talking about? How about it?
At the end of that Gracie, the end of it,
Gracie in all caps and exclamation
points. Preposterous. Right?
So I was embarrassed by it because I
think that we all have an obligation to be
as honest and as open as possible.
When we're assessing our friends,
our loved ones, our brothers and sisters
performances, there's a, and there's,
there's this weird thing that people do
when they start getting biased and they
start disregarding the
accomplishments of others.
If the fight was completely reversed,
I would absolutely say men boiler
Gracie dominated. Eddie Bravo was crazy.
He just, he just knew how to sweep
them. He got them into bad positions.
He fucked up Eddie's leg. Me. Very brave
of Eddie that he didn't tap. But man,
I was super impressed with Euler.
Hey,
I don't know if they're
going to do it again.
Maybe Eddie would like to reconsider.
Knowing that Oilers game is so tricky.
If they were totally opposite, but there
weren't opposite. So when I look at it,
I have to look at it. Yeah, I'm on
my biased. Absolutely. You know,
I, I look, I love the Gracies but Eddie's
one of my best friends on the planet.
You know, you're, you're probably top
two human beings that I love more.
I love you buddy.
But a fairly decent,
my two friends that need to
put in a disclaimer, like
I just gotta tell you now,
it's all, these are my two best friends
of all times, so I'm, I'm sure I'm biased,
but even being biased
objectively looking at it,
I get sad because I think that
what they did was an embarrassment.
That's what I think I want
to know is where the fuck
are the pickles, bro. I know.
I think we ate them all.
We've got to call up Grillo's pickle.
I personally love the,
I love how you started that.
I think it was great for
one hand goes on the mat,
you slap the mat and the other
hand goes up and you start waving.
That was a wrestling and I
never wrestle and I thought,
I thought for sure he's going to
think I'm going to pull guard,
but let me give a wrestling look for a
second to freak them out and then I'll,
I didn't even know you were doing it
was so great. Bam out there. It's hard.
It's hard when people get
emotionally attached to results.
emotionally attached to fight,
you know you've made a great case. You
just need does that, this guy every fight.
Of course. It's a great,
a great assessment.
Well that's what it is.
You know what I mean? Even
you know and that that head who I love,
you know his,
his take on it was that you didn't pass
the boiler Elio challenge or the Elio
test filter that your, your, your style
would be ineffective in a street fight,
which is,
it's,
it's unfortunately ignorant because if
they knew that if punches were involved,
your style works better,
your style's more effective when the is
trying to punch because if a guy on top
was trying to punch, he's given up
under hooks. He's given up over hooks,
giving up a lot of shit when you
start throwing your arms around.
And the only reason I'm in court,
a guard is because there's not
punching exactly that was punching.
I would get in deeper
right away because that,
since you could use your hands on top
100% for to keep me away and rape,
choke me and do all this
stuff that people do,
but it's because you're not punching.
Have you ever fought MMA?
Never.
What'd you ever met will not tell them
when you're telling a story about how
they were trying to set you up.
Tell that story because that's
a crazy story I've told.
I've told that story before.
You don't even have to say
the name of the organization.
You don't have to say the
name of the organization.
I'll say I'll set it up so you don't have
to know the name of the fighter or the
organization.
Uh,
a prominent Japanese organization that
may or may not still be in business came
up
general in Los Angeles and they
wanted to talk to him about having a,
a, an MMA. There's no, there's no, uh,
there's no blind in there. Is there some,
you guys liked that wine though?
They wanted to talk to him about
having a UFC fight and they told us no,
no, no, it wasn't MMA grappling
match. They go, no, no, no,
no, no, no. But there was the,
oh, that's the [inaudible]
was a grappling match.
That's the only reason I sat down and
talked to them because I wasn't trying to
do MMA, but they go, oh, we
want to get you to find a, uh,
a super fight, grappling match. We're
going to mix it in to our MMA show.
And I met them at the Beverly
Wilshire radice hotel and La.
I met him there and the in the lobby and
a representative of this organization.
And I said, okay, I'll do it, you know,
and they go, well, how about if we, uh,
we made it a MMA fighter. So
I said, well, I don't do it.
Then they know it will,
but we'll make it so that you win.
And then the guy who brought me there,
I looked over at the guy who brought me,
looked it all up.
I looked at him and I said,
what the fuck is going on here? What do
you mean? What? What do you say that?
What can
you possibly say that?
What did we make it so they can?
There's a lot of setting on you there
that sounds like they're setting up.
They're setting you up to go there.
You're going to win and then you get in
there and they got beats the fuck out of
here. I would've never, I would've
never done your dishonorable anyway.
Why should they do that for you?
This is Jap.
Japanese culture is very
different than American culture.
If they set you up and you go over there,
you ain't suing. You're not saying, hey,
we had an agreement to a fixed fight
going to be in Japan. This was the Yakuza.
I'm excited for this fight. Yeah,
heavyweights. Tough finale. Heavyweights.
Vito or Miranda and a Antonio.
Carlos junior is his nickname.
Antonio only house. Oh,
Antonio only has four or five.
Very similar to me with only four
fights on the ultimate fighter finale.
Interesting. Next, Luther
is his nickname. That's us.
That's what happened in [inaudible] name
is Brandon shop. Cut them some slack.
I forget man. It's hard to keep up.
I lost the finale to Roy Nelson,
but I only had four fights of Roy
Head, whatever, 25 former world champ.
But the thing that helped me,
and I've never told you this show,
the thing that helped me, um,
I was in a dark place after.
I've never lost any right.
A fight.
I lost that fight and I watched the replay
back and uh, during my walked out, uh,
Joe on the broadcast goes,
listen,
Brendan has a very tall order.
Roy Nelson is a hell of a fighter.
He could jump in division
right now and beat anyone.
Brendan will has four fights no
matter what happens in this fight.
Brendan is going to go on and have
a great career. And honestly, man,
that helped me out so much. That's
awesome dude. I'm so glad that help.
That was totally true.
You know there's a thing about those,
those ultimate fighters,
situations like that where you
get a guy who's gotten mad,
mad fucking fights behind
him and Roy Roy was fuck,
he was real good and wasn't known for.
It was weird.
The show made him known for
being a knockout puncher. Yeah,
but before that he fought.
He fought Andre or loss you.
He came in the house got robbed.
You fight.
That was when they were doing
that bullshit. That elite Xc,
they would stand you up. You'd be
like in the ground for 15 minutes.
He was inside control working
on a Kamora locked the, Yup.
Double wrist lock. However, either
way you paint it Orlowski Tko Odom.
He did the only guy to ever do it.
But I think that he was like
more uncomfortable about
taking shots back down to
different writing. But it's
interesting when you think about that,
the fact that he got [inaudible] and since
then he's been invulnerable to shots.
I agree. But look at Verdugo for
doom. Hit Him with everything.
But the goddamn kitchen sink.
Not really a heavy hitter though,
is he need the fucking shit out
of his face. It's true. You know,
and he's taking bombs from you
name. It took bombs from Cro. Cop.
He took bombs from everybody and Chubb.
Julie,
how about for landed some career don't
Santos Sto Santos. I tell you what.
They just announced Roy. Mark Hunt. Yeah.
Back to back to the
ultimate fighter finale.
There's a lot of fights like most most uh,
commissions went st you in that fight,
right?
Guy With four and the guy was third right
here. Going back a way. Good. Exactly.
But because it's the show, I didn't
know it hasn't been part of a cautions.
Took those things into account.
I really dare you do fight ever.
If you don't know that I'm
learning, man. I, this is my,
this is my education. Oh, don't do it.
Nice mix in boxing.
If a guy has an extensive
amateur background, if a
guy's like world champion,
amateur boxer and you know,
he's fighting in Cuban,
then all sudden needs in America.
And they,
one of the challenge for the title of
his third fight, that's not unheard.
That Cuban program is amazing.
Well brushing as well.
There's a Russian guy recently challenged
for a title and you'd only been boxing
professionally for very
short period of time. Well,
I went from fighting Billy
McGee and Denver. You know,
where he was scared and you know,
I could tell I was beating the more
ready at the weigh ins to fight and Roy
Nelson in Las Vegas. I was like, what?
The vine fire baptism by fire did you
just got to deceptives knew about him when
you went in there?
I mean,
I thought 100% I was getting knocked
him out in the first round. I was very,
I was very naive. Roy has got deceptive
time. I wouldn't change it for anything.
No Man. What? He dropped
that bomb on Nogueira.
That was one of the saddest knockouts
of all time stiff. Dude. That was scary.
Sick,
sick fight,
but ruin Roy knocked out Nogueira it
was a career ender. It was like, whoa.
That was a sign that the fucking wheels
have come off the wagon. This is over.
That was reassured that she had
thought he killed. Just measure it,
wrote it and money killed. When he hit
Congo. I was like, oh no. Oh my God,
you killed Congo. You know what's crazy?
He didn't even start. You Killed Kenny.
Oh my God.
You Killed Congo.
He didn't even start striking until
2009 yeah. Roids a special special.
That's crazy animal. You
know he hit me. He didn't.
People think hit me in the jawline. Oh,
show up. You got a weak ass John Grant.
These 265 pounds, shit happens. We in the
face. It's weird. Your brain shuts off.
However, he hit me behind the
air directly behind the outage,
right behind the air.
He threw a double jab.
I slipped the first one and my head was
out of position. Right hand, right plan.
The year before that though, I was putting
on a clinic fight me now what's up,
son? Don't have four fights
anymore. What's up? You want
it to archive? You know,
I don't care. I don't that I'd
rather fight, uh, other people.
But if it were to happen, yeah, it'd be a
totally different story. You know, Eddie,
what we were saying about,
um,
how the Gracies were saying what
you did didn't pass the Elio filter.
What was fucked up about that was what
we were talking about earlier about when
here on fought Andre Galvao and he had
that match with Andre Galvao and just,
he was showing his defense. He let him
pass his guard and let them mount him.
He led them out.
You gotta yell or respect that.
That's some gangster shit out.
Look that criticism though. The
criticism. I'll be honest, the OPS team,
right? Henna and heat on
her, like my brother's band,
but I haven't seen any of this stuff.
I watched the match.
I don't see any of that stuff.
They've done nothing. I know that.
I know they like you. I have [inaudible]
me about you. I don't matter.
You know what? I don't see any of it.
So I that's why people that go shops,
we didn't quite cause he's teamed
Gracie. No, I'm not on it. I
don't know. I haven't seen any of that.
I watched metamorris. I was like, damn,
that was dope for Jujitsu.
It was the most talked about Jujitsu
match since Brenden's shop Cyborg, not
[inaudible].
It was
very talked about. And you know, I'm
just not that I'm anti Metamorris,
I'm a hundred percent pro. I'll
promote that show to the day it stops.
He's just fucking Christ.
I love that.
He can't go five minutes
without talking freaks out.
I love that they're doing it.
But I think you gotta be,
you gotta be really careful with your
assessments of a situation if the UFC did
that,
save the UFC,
talked about Tj Dillashaw and Hanan Barao
and painted it all about Hanan Barao
being tough and amazing how he got through
that fight and it was incredible. Oh,
you're saying after the fact they did,
it was a little bit of that before a
fight. Well, that was before the fight.
No one thought that was going to happen
the way. I mean, I guess maybe Tj did,
but I didn't think,
I don't know Tj,
but thought it was gonna
be a really tough fight.
I thought Tj has chances to win
because he's got great endurance.
If you could take it into third,
fourth and fifth round and
push a tremendous matchups
when you get in the top 10
it's about matching. Number nine can be
a horror metric, number one. But anyway,
if the UFC painted it in an
incredibly inaccurate way,
so imagine after the fact [inaudible]
professional or unprofessional.
That's what it felt.
If they,
if they talked about the Tj Dillashaw
Hanan Barao fi and obviously that is a
more dominant example because Tj just
lit hand and brow on fires, even a fight.
It was reduced. It was amazing. It
was the best performance of ever seen.
It's I agree and biggest upset because
everyone's like Matt Serra GSP cause this
was five rounds of a straight
ass whooping clinic son.
There was nothing wound clinic and then
stops him in the fifth with a fucking
head kick. I mean the shit was off the
charts. Ass Kid was off the charts.
But what Eddie did,
toiler was Hoyle.
Lou was never once in a dominant position,
never once in a position where he was
threatening Eddie and Eddie without a
doubt, fucked his leg up. So for them
to paint this inaccurate picture of it,
and then in their credit corrected it.
Once they experience criticism and
actually took the original post down from
Instagram,
they deleted it from Instagram,
which is essentially admitting that
you fucked up. Right, right. I mean,
that's what it is.
It did.
Heuler did you talk to another after
the fight at the post fight? Uh,
conference, right? We have a cool look.
It's there. Cool. Right afterwards.
They were cool before it. Sure. Here's
the deal, man. This is the Internet.
This is a different world. You can't
get by just on your name anymore.
You gotta be cool across the board.
You don't get any free passes.
You didn't win the lottery.
Everything is what it is. And every,
and if you pretend it's not what it is,
and everybody can see that they
think you're a con. That's just,
that's just how it goes today. It's
a different world. And you know,
I appreciate what [inaudible] Lt. Wow.
His beautiful mountain. This fucking dude,
this kid is in a ps four. No two. I'll
tell you right now, both of these guys,
well they're both can have a career in
the UFC. Whoever wins or loses obviously.
However,
neither Wilms find that heavyweight,
I think one way to at two 14 one way
to get to 12 or something like that.
Two 30 and two 18 Miranda on the
bottoms to 30. And that's apparent.
That's on his bio in the UFC. That
might not be accurate. You might, uh,
he might be preparing for two oh five
after this. Eddie, is there a guy,
a Jujitsu guy just to guy that you
would really like to fight, that you're,
that that is a huge challenge to you
that we can kind of get that fucking card
pass sick. Ooh, he was trying to get
back. He was trying to get back to,
um,
he was trying to hip escape and the dude
pass his garden got into side control
like a wizard. But look at
this. Yeah, man. Antonio,
Carlos junior is a bad motherfucker.
No, you know what I think, um,
I mean I think that match
was super important. I was
thinking of shooting poor.
Important for you.
I think it was super important for
Jujitsu and I think that it showed that
Jujitsu matches can be super fucking
exciting and I think it opens up the door
to a possible future in having
some sort of a professional,
oh, but Ooh, that's attacking
the, he's attacking.
Would you change anything?
Would you change the rules of metamorris
though as in is something they can do
to make it, I dunno. Well,
submission only submission only for sure.
But since Metamorris isn't a
tournament matches, they should,
they should.
They should.
It should be more a winner take all or
serious difference between show money and
submission money. Like it should
be, uh, 1000 bucks to show for you.
No, right. Or 7,000. If you
sell it, it's gotta be right.
Go for this. And you have to, you
have to, it's gotta be like that.
If you're going to have
single matches the money,
we'll create the urgency that
creates the cause, a entertained.
Otherwise you get, otherwise you get this
weird kind of stalemate. 20 minutes, man,
you've got to make it worth it.
That's what we're trying to do in my,
my tournament is all about fixing the,
the boringness of Jujitsu.
That's what I'm trying to do.
I'm not trying to make money
putting together this tournament.
Money is not a goal at all.
I'm not,
I'm losing money on my first tournament.
We're just trying to put
together Jujitsu for TV. Can we?
It should be on TV already,
but it's not on teams triangle.
Oh, so close. Beautiful Pass. He's he,
he's San Antonio kid is nasty man. I
like, he hesitated on that cinch, man.
He had that triangle
there for fucking obese
too, man. Look, but look at
Antonio's back to his half guard.
Sneaking up the back door on them. Is
there a guy you'd like to do this crazy.
They're stopping him from throwing
those elbows. That is so ridiculous.
They stopped the thigh. Why?
Because they're illegal.
The 12 to six elbows and
legal on your thought. Why?
It's so stupid because it's a rule that
was at 12 to six elbows are illegal
anywhere.
It was created when they were worried
about people killing people and way back
in the day in the back of the head,
no, no, no, no. He's hitting the five.
No it was from I,
I've explained it a million times and
you've never paid attention once cause you
not a real MMA fan.
So I'll do it one last time on,
there are other people that aren't big.
John McCarthy was first talking to the
athletic commissions trying to get the
UFC legal. They wouldn't let the downward
elbow in because they saw those karate
demonstrations at two
o'clock in the morning.
We're dudes would break bricks with,
they're not bullshit. So stupid.
It's amazing the dumbest shit ever.
And it proves that you're not a real MMA
fan cause you don't know that. So now,
now that we've established that,
don't ever say a guy can hit a guy
with a right hand. Again man, the club,
I want to be in a club. And who do you
want? Who is there? A guy out there,
a Jujitsu guy that you
would love to fight,
who you think would be
a huge challenge to you,
whoever would generate the biggest
pay day. Wait, hold on. Okay,
so let me give it, let me tell
you, I don't hate anybody.
I'm not trying to challenge hold.
Let me throw like Floyd Mayweather,
throw a name out. I'm not going
to call it. Listen, listen.
Just to preparing for that
match was very stressful, okay?
It took me away from my family all day.
I'm thinking about training. It just,
it just put my life on hold is stressful.
I had to do it and I did it a hundred
percent trained like a fucking Olympian
you proved yourself after.
After that match.
I don't want to put any names out there.
I'm not going to challenge anybody.
I'm going to rest for a
while and when I come back,
the only names I'm going to bring up,
I'm not going to bring up any names now
on names that are going to generate the
most money. At the end of this
page. You have nothing to prove.
Nothing to prove you did it. Yeah.
When it gets Marcella Garcia,
he would fucking smash.
Don't move the official.
He's a really good friend of mine.
Garcia is fucking amazing.
He bet his head as he was taking
them down as he was taking Marcel.
Like I said it that he said he already
had them submit it. On a side note,
this fight is dope. Brian, would you
ship your upper for two
seconds about digit time?
I find a hard time believing you really
want to know the answer to that question.
I think you just wanted to talk.
This is to win the ultimate
fighter heavyweight,
Brazil Skype chat and not talk over
people. Man, you're really bad at it.
I am not talking over this.
It was just talking to San Antonio.
Carlos junior is a beast. Man.
I'm super impressed by this kid.
Are you talking about this fight we're
talking about Eddie Bravo. Bravo.
What about Metamorris? Yeah. You
guys now tune into the fights.
You and Joe finally tuning into
the fights and scolding me.
One thing I want to make clear before we
end. Henzel Gracie, I love you to death.
The Gracies are a giant family.
There's so many awesome Gracie's in there.
There's only a couple that you know I'm
not particularly interested in hanging
out with, but there's a lot
of graces that are awesome.
Clark Gracie Hoes Gracie's, one of them
arose grace, I'm sorry, hose Rosemary's.
He's one of the coolest chicks on the
planet. So Henner heroes. There's people,
there's people in my family
that I don't want to talk to.
You know what I'm saying?
So the Gracies are giant.
So Hansa is one of my
favorite people of all time.
Be Real clear. I love here
on, I love Henner. I love
luck. I love all those dudes.
I do.
I think they're awesome.
I just think the way that the situation
was handled, Ooh good. I'm done.
Way Better. And if they were
having a debate with someone,
if they had to have a debate with a,
say a guy like Jeff Glover,
an impartial observer, I
guarantee you there, Jeff Glover,
his point of view and their point of view,
it would be vastly different.
I just don't think that they handled
it well either way. Good for Jujitsu.
We're talking [inaudible] happen
that way. Mother of Jujitsu.
Joe Him the money.
Hi Brian.
I'm going to shut down my life
again and train and do swim sprints,
which are jumping. That freezer
swims friends, you know,
it's like sprinting and a pool out.
You're just swimming as fast as you can.
Just die, dude. Fucking you
said water swim sprints.
That's crazy. Hey, sorry. I'm
not a suppression on last week.
That's where I figured it was.
But a week from now on podcast
talking about how he does swim sprint,
you know I will. No, I
will do stuff. I go, I go.
Especially if we have as a chicken,
I need my, I need my sprint.
I gotta get my spreadsheet.
He has a chest off the chicken to be like,
I find it's swim sprints.
I helped me the most,
you know when I was training for
the worlds, I guess whatever.
I never wanted to fight.
Gets busy with other stuff or bought a
film project clock stop really close with
Marky mark.
It was a time
I liked that. When Martin how to
vote strength and conditioning.
I was just naturally supple.
Believe me,
I like good friends with Leonardo
Dicaprio. You had a Frank Young. Okay.
That's right.
It wasn't,
you know I played pickup basketball
with him once he was wearing a burette.
Did he dunk on you put it in your face?
No,
I was more athletic than he is.
Tie your hair up.
You very specific. If you're a dude
and you have like one of those,
remember when Hickson Gracie had that?
I think going with that. That's fine.
That's fine. Brian's, you have like
rubber bands but which you can't have.
You can't have a Beretta can have
a Brett. Nope. CanNot allow it.
And he had chuck Ladell can if you want
it to. If you're leaning on Keppra,
you can do whatever you want. Probably.
No you can't. It's 100% super nice guy.
Enough money that he really doesn't
give a fuck. And like the girl,
he drives a Prius girls that wouldn't
fuck him because he was wearing a burette.
You don't want those girls,
you know? That's right.
He was swearing a burette
to keep chicks away.
He's like I told you when Carlos got
the back here, this is the, by the way,
this good is a monster,
least fight heavy
fight companion podcast of all
time. Yeah. Apologize to every,
for everybody. For these guys. I apologize
for Brian for nutshell nub about, sorry,
I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm a Jujitsu
freak bro. So he's a freak bro.
He's going to train eventually.
I lived one of these days if he could
just get a place to move closer to his
house.
So he has an open invitation to train
with Eddie Bravo or where Henna and here
on Gracie has never been to it for so
long. Launch a on drive too far away.
Too Far. What's the best as far as
the biggest coolest Jujitsu Gym?
Is it Gracie in um, torrents
be? It's amazing. Right? Salt.
So many students for me to train with.
Is that the biggest place you've ever
been to? Because I've seen it online.
They have like extra rooms and shit.
Bunch of private rooms and big old mat.
The Mat space,
it's like a custom made Jamey right where
they have like a tarp over like some
maps that are underneath the does that
Matt get does that. Matt gets slippery.
It does.
When you get sweaty it's very slippery
cause it's not like as good as like a
Tommy. Those flat ones, those
are the best. Right? Yeah.
They have the wanes. I brought up
the header one time. He told me,
I forget the reason I ask when
it's slippery, your bowel,
you need more balance actually lets you,
when you're winning you're sweaty.
It's super slippery. Yeah. You've got
to get used to that. So is it better?
It's better to be on a slippery
surface surface for a three technique.
I don't know. Probably that make sense
to you. Right on ice. That's a bad pass.
Imagine if you could pass on ice. No, it
totally makes sense. The one thing though,
sucks up fat bag of Dicks for cause.
If you're doing any kind of
striking train wrestling, oh yeah.
Either one of those.
You're going to hurt your ACL.
He can't.
You can't get your foot in the good
position if you don't have traction.
You can't choose where your feet go when
you're scrambling. They just give out.
Tear out their needs because of traction.
Bolles especially, you're right.
Damn football with artificial hearts,
astro turf. What are we doing?
Who's idea was that? Those
see meant that was green. God,
God. Oh yeah. My high school football
field was astro turf. Way To go,
but it gives you an
unrealistic environment to
kind of Denver, they can. Oh,
with new technologies. Grass, special
seats were good seasons there.
It's fricking greenish shit. Everything's
green. Just have to heat the frown.
The ground's too hard when they
throw astroturf when it's just,
it's just not fucking worth it.
It's just cheaper to,
you got to think high
schools. They're like, oh,
we don't have to pay anyone and
take care of you. They do that now.
Is it still astroturfing different? That's
a combo net and hold now it's like a,
it's like a fake grass.
It has the feel of the grass has these
little rubber pellets in it like uh,
a lot of football fields or that
now that's the latest ship graph.
Rubber graphing, rubber grass with these
rubber pellets. I'm going to Google it.
Rip Apart. When you run on it with
cleats, know that like these you'll,
you'll like when you take off your cleats,
you have these little black balls are
rubber and it, but it's like, it's soft.
Like grass,
Eco Turf.
Is that what it is? Sure. Why not? Hmm.
Back to this shit.
It looks fucking really shit man.
There you go. That's crazy. I
have it. I have it in my garage.
That looks real as shit.
That's weird. It's amazing.
It's pretty cool. That's feel
great. It can be plasticky. No,
it's made of lamb skin feels good.
Another lamps feels natural.
Alaskan company. It's called field
field turf. There you go. Yeah.
That would be the ultimate.
If it was made from lambskin,
then grass would tear off like
natural grass, you know word.
Hmm. Interesting. Yeah.
This is what it's called.
Field Turf. It's pretty cool.
That's bad ass man. Field Turf. Huh?
His Antonio Carlos Junior. Definitely
one. That kid gets a bright future.
He's a bad ass. Anyways,
back down the NFL.
How many stadiums and off the top of
your head do you think I have this shit?
I would say is there a hybrid? Like
there's some that's kind of like that,
but there's real grass grown and they
got like some crazy hydro buckeyes stone,
like super high tech where they're growing
grass. This shit out. The sunlight,
the real,
that shit man.
It's more predominant in colleges I'd say
in the NFL, not, I mean not even half,
not even half of them are.
I want to know what the latest is
in the NFL with that shit field turf
revolution.
I'm getting that stuff from my garden.
Why would you do the Super Lane?
You could actually have ground fucking,
I don't want it.
I want,
I want it to look green and I don't want
to deal with that because we live in
California. Bugs here though. You
guys all in a nature on a regular day,
five or six bucks, whatever. I'm not
using, I'm not using Miranda around.
I've never seen the, you
gotta be honest. Jungle.
At one point in your life you
had to like in Asia, right?
I was in Indonesia and then in the right,
how did you deal with bugs?
You heard them coming from,
oh,
well it's as loud as grand
central station. The jungle.
There are bugs that are so crazy.
First of all,
you have to worry about the soldier
ants. So you, when you slept the,
uh, no, you had to worry about soldier
ants that would come in and when they were
hunting, they did everything in their
path. And it's for whatever reason,
when they climb on you,
they bite you in unison.
They like as a signal or something,
you go into shock and then you get heat.
So what you do is you will get eaten by
ants in the jungle all the time. Yeah.
So what you want to do is when you sleep,
you want to make sure it
was the hunt at night.
You see you have a raised platform, it's
on posts and you have to dip the posts.
You have to paint the posts in Turpentine
Cause Turpentine, we'll stop them.
If you don't do that,
they will come up the posts and it will
come into your place and they will kill
you. Now sometimes you can wake
up covering a Nance soldier, ants.
You won't die because they're foraging.
They're not hunting. So you sit there,
you don't move, don't move. And
they'll coat over you and, and not,
not of you kill one. I don't know.
You fucked up, but you don't move.
Don't move.
They will go over you and pass over you.
So millions of ants will pass over you.
But that's why in the rain
forest you use a hammock.
You put it between two trees,
sleep and you,
the ropes that hold the hammock are
also dipped in Turpentine. So and Oh,
and when you're in the rain forest,
I had to carry you think you think
off works for this. Mosquitoes off.
Get the fuck Outta here.
They laugh at that shit.
You carry a sulfur coil,
a sulfur coil that you,
that you burn and it's burning
sulfur in front of you.
That's how you have to hang out in the
rain for us because otherwise bugs will
eat you alive. Lot of
people, man. Elephants people
like go into an elephants.
Because I was studying, I was
studying orangutans. I thought,
I thought I wanted to be a natural.
I'm 20, I want to be a naturalist,
I want to live in the jungle. And
I was studying orangutans. So you,
you track orangutans all day.
Uh, do you know what that means?
Collect their feces and sift through
it and figure out what they're eating.
So Jane Goodall,
you think she went through a lot of,
cause they never talked
about Jane Goodall. Yeah.
Jane Goodall was a different thing
cause she'd dealt with chimps.
Now when you deal with chimps versus
orangutans, Orangutans are fine.
They're not going to kill you.
Chimps are our live in groups or I can't
tell it's a, what about the bugs though?
Had I it that's in that first
butts in the Congo. So yeah,
you're dealing with major bugs. So they
just never talked about them movies.
They never talk about how she got attacked
by bugs. Uh, I love that transition.
And if you guys saw that, sorry.
Anyways, no bed bugs. Bugs.
And the biggest thing in the
rant this Antonio kids bugs.
Yeah. He's a beast, man.
I had an experience and you can wait
in like whatever he decides to do is,
you mean I had an experience,
the worst vacation of my life.
I had friends go do this, go to
Costa Rica. We're going to party.
I thought costs streak was like
Cancun. Yeah. They'd be like, yeah,
we're going to party it. Ed
Clay. He goes, dude, it's just,
it's me and like 10 people,
chicks. We've gotta fuck.
We got this man Shin on in Costa
Rica that we're going to party.
And I'm like thinking mansion, Cancun
Party beach. So I said, fuck it.
Let's go. We land in Costa Rica. Um,
I thought we were in the city where
we're going to party in San Pedro or San
Jose or something. They go, oh no,
we're just staying here for the tonight,
the mansions. We got another take another
plane to get to the mansion. I'm like,
Oh shit. We get into this prop plane.
There's like six of us in there going,
Holy Shit. Go. We'd be
like, go into Jurassic Park,
land on the outskirts of Costa
Rica in this jungle town.
Wow. And I'm thinking, I,
I hate the jungle. I'm not trying to go
to the jungle. I don't like bugs at all.
I can't deal with that shit.
That's a phobia of mine.
I don't want to go scuba diamond.
Right. Joss fucked that up from,
I don't want to go into a jungle.
I don't want to fuck with bugs.
I'll go snowboarding all day,
but I can go in and throw a damn jungle,
see a DVD of it. That's
it. So I got tricked. Uh,
they didn't do it on purpose,
but really I fucked up.
I thought it was like can't coon.
I didn't know where going into a,
we get to the mansion. I'm
fucking freaking out inside.
I don't want to spoil.
I don't want to seem like a big, seem
like a big pussy. I'm like, fuck,
I got to hold it inside. It's daytime
and go, Shit. What happens at night?
We're in a jungle. There's a mansion
in a jungle. It's cool, but holy fuck,
we're going to get killed by these bugs.
I walk into my room,
there's the ceiling doesn't connect to
the sidewalls cause if you don't have
bugs, don't bother you. You
don't. You just open the shit up.
You want that breeze coming through
your house. I walk into my room,
there's 50 bees in my room.
I put my bags down,
I go downstairs and there's a
guy that do to own the houses.
Uncle stays there all the time ago.
There's bees in my room,
should I? I'm trying to keep
my pussy penis under control.
I don't let anybody see the fear, but I'm
thinking about when the sun goes down,
what's going to happen? So what's going
to happen? One of the jungle, oh shit,
it's summertime. Turn on the ceiling
fan, but don't turn it on on blast.
Just bear it. Put it on low. It'll
make them uncomfortable in the flyaway.
Damn. You don't want to make them
uncomfortable, right? Yeah, I go,
I got to sleep in that motherfucker.
So I turned on the fan on, on low,
left it there. We all take off
to, uh, to go. Everyone needs,
you had to have your own ATC, four wheeler
ATV. You got to have your own ones.
So we were going to, as soon as
you get there, leave your bags.
We got to get our transport.
Everyone's got to have their own.
We're in the junk because if you
don't have your own fucking ATV,
you're going to be left behind.
So we get in the van to go to this
to get our ATVs. And I said, are,
are you guys uh, worried about
the bees in your room? Oh my God.
There was like a playboy playmate
chick. She was there too, so yeah.
Did you see all the bees? What are we
gonna do about it? I'm mad at Dad. Yeah.
And anyways when the sun, we went
into town, got an atds I bought,
I went to the local store and bought
all their off about all their off.
As we went back to the, we went
back to the mansion. There's a pool,
it looks like Jay z's mansion,
pool,
Infinity Pool and then you see the coast
of Costa Rica. The Sun was going down.
It was like from dusk till dawn.
I went in the bathroom or just drenched
my whole body. I used off like Mousse.
I put I drenched my whole body and
we sat by the pool and I'm like,
I'm not going to be attack. And you
know what? The bugs came out first.
The frogs come out and I'm like,
oh my God, what do all these frogs?
I thought we were being attacked
by frogs and the old man goes,
the frogs are going to be your best
friend. Watch when the bugs come out.
The frogs,
you just see just like Braveheart
of frogs and books shot.
You never see the same bug twice.
You never see the same book twice.
I had to go and we had to get an,
we had to go six miles,
six hours upstream to where the,
where the nature preserve was. The,
we get into this rickety boat,
Rick,
and he like a raft and there are
saltwater crocodiles everywhere. So,
and there are accidents all the time
when people crashing out of boats because
they're drunk or they're whatever. And
people, you know, getting and right.
Two weeks before this, uh, they, they,
they had to shoot this crocodile is huge.
Salt water crocodile killed a kid.
They shot it with an m 16 like
15 times and then it didn't die.
So they put electrical cables into the
water and electric heater to death. Right.
There's no more.
So then there's
that. We get there. My
sister the first day,
puts her foot in her sandal and
goes in her inner clog and goes,
my foot's on fire. My Foot's on
fire poles, her foot. It's a,
it's a fire and it's one of those ants.
Any other vacation storage,
Dad, it, man, that's
[inaudible] for too long.
You gotta jump in. No, he
finished his story and I was just,
I was and I was halfway through
his piggy back. Nowhere near done,
but I'm going to end it. Joe, you think
fabulous can win this fight at all?
Well,
it's a crazy fight when you think that
meal chick is number seven heavyweight in
the world.
Fabio Maldonado not even ranked as a
heavyweight light has a light heavyweight,
not ranked light heavyweight. He's,
yeah, he's a light heavyweight.
Not ranked as the light heavyweight.
Probably somebody that one 85 no one is
a guy who carries body fat fighting as a
light heavyweight,
but no one has also been an incredibly
durable guy and undefeated as a pro
boxer. Yeah, but it's deep. It's
deep. It was a train partner of mine.
Homeboy can wrestle, man, I think. I think
we'll see some of his wrestling tonight.
I wonder. He's a smart fighter and
one of us are going to try and do
Fabio Maldonado. He is a, he's a
fucking blood and guts fighter man.
He is the epitome of a
blood and guts fighter.
That guy can take a
fucking beating that hair.
Very few guys can take a
beating like Maldonado, Ken,
and he's got vicious body shots. His
left hook to the body is fucking nasty,
but he's going to be so outsized.
I mean he's nowhere near the same size.
Like when the two of them
get inside the octagon,
I think you're going to see a big size
of security for stupid meal check.
How much? How much more?
How much heavier Steve Bay?
Well Maldonado waste two oh five when
I weighed in at two 12 tonight I think
ma'am and then Steve Bay
was around two 30 God, look,
that's not that bad when you consider
the fact that cane regular fights guys
that are much heavier than that, but we
gotta you gotta think he looks small,
right?
The Nanos a small light heavyweight
and he's not exactly a shredded,
uh, to 12 great boxing. No ma'am.
It was nominal bonds. Really sweet.
It becomes really interesting.
Are they fighting and heavyweight short
notice because junior dos Santos in
steep, it was supposed to
be the headliner. Junior
got hurt. Had to pull out.
They broke his hand. Yeah. You look,
what's interesting about it is because
so much is on the line for Steve Bay,
so it's, it's really a,
it's not real. It's a lose.
Lose a steeper if you don't destroy
this guy. People are like, Dang man,
what the hell happened?
Even if he puts up some sort of fight
and he's essentially saving the card.
It's really interesting
to know heavyweights were
prominent enough to take that
position. You know? Thinking about how
this is a short, I didn't get a call.
I would have took the fight. What'd you're
talking about? What? It took the fight.
I was in shape. I could've fought Andre
Arlovski three weeks ago. Mom, my,
my resting heart rate on
Friday was 37 Whoa. Holy Shit.
That's ridiculous. That's crazy. Mine
65 damn man. I got to start training.
I'm going to do some call spreads yours.
Yours is 112 specs. Brian, back to Brian.
He brought it back. I'm just saying,
dude, I got to start taking my training
more seriously. It's crazy. Yeah.
You keep bringing it back to yourself,
but I'm going to videotape it so of
course I'm going to bring it back in the
conversation. We'll look at this
getting all these sensitive girl.
You're getting bullied, bullied
online quickly. Seriously.
Guys, online attack. Joe,
stand up for me and everybody.
Was it good fucking, I'm
actually, I have a lot of Jon.
Anik was telling me he was surprised they
didn't call me to step in for this way.
It's interesting. I would've thought,
well, you know, I guess they will.
You were originally scheduled to fight
hunt. What happened in that fight?
He kept saying he was hurt and then
we're supposed to fight in June.
They said it wouldn't be ready
to fight in June in New Zealand.
So then I was like, dude, I had a fight.
I can't wait to go like that if you're
gonna eat, it helps. It sounds so cool.
How loud? So loud. It sounds cool to
you because your heart sounds so cool.
Then I choose snacks like Mark Hunt.
He kept getting prolonged, prolonged,
and then I was like, dude,
I have to have a fight. I,
I don't want to sit out that year.
And then they called me the Andrei
Arlovski so I didn't want to wait and now
he's fighting Roy, which be like,
oh, shop. Are You mad? Hell No.
That's an epic fight. I can't wait to
see that fight. That's a great fight.
Believe me, my time will come.
Oh Shit. That was a fucking,
he just threw down a
declaration. Mark Hunt's time
will come. Dodged a bullet son.
Uncle Dana saved Ya. Whoa.
See that? Everybody pause.
Just pause. Let that sit. Yeah.
I think Fabio Maldonado got the
call because he's Brazilian as well,
but I know I heard he texts Joe Silva
was like, Yo, I want this fight now.
Probably wanting to fight in Brazil.
Fabio Maldonado is an example of never
looking at a guy with his shirt off and
think he's a pussy.
Just by the way he looks like they
fade or kind of everyone knows that.
Well thanks. Thanks for taking
any other brain under guys.
I guess it's shit.
I'm Brian [inaudible].
Brian [inaudible] guys apparently
shit on Brian Saturday,
I can't think. Well, Billy Madison quote
for how about fucking mark? But seriously,
we were talking about Mark Hunt who
looks like deceiving more than mark.
Hi Roy Nelson,
and they're fine.
They're like professional
athlete to up my ass.
I grew up with island people and I would
look at Mark Hunt and not fuck with
them. I don't care what you wrote. What I
to fuck with market. I grew up in Tahiti.
That's what I thought you couldn't look
you could you remind me of Tahiti and
the funny, Brian's a bit of the heat.
He told the story. Brian, good question.
Why don't you talk to him?
When you went on vacation and all the
incidents you saw [inaudible] this is
Tahiti. I had my shirt,
shirt. I watched it. Question.
Thank you for asking a question actually.
When I was in Tahiti,
have you ever seen the snakes in Tahiti?
Oh, they're great snacks. Well, Hey,
I was playing with a snake and Indonesia.
That is six minutes of my life.
I'll never get back
playing with the with a stick, but what
they call the cost comes up and goes,
young man,
that snake bites you.
You will be dead in a half hour and we
are six hours from any hospital and I
went, okay, I'll stop playing with that
snake. Good stories. Stop the animal.
Good story.
Good story about snakes guys.
That was funny. I bet. Right? I
see Eddie and he's got my back.
You to shit around Karen.
When your back's against the wall,
you learn how to turn it around.
Look at Steve by chewing gum.
He looks pretty calm areas,
lady and gentlemen. Steve Bay.
He looks hard.
You can work that in you does your act.
You could be like anybody knows
a lot about MMA but he just,
has anybody ever walked to the
oxygen? I'm looking at higher. God,
he looks ready to as high as fuck.
He does look super,
super high also as a full time job as
a firefighter. Is that right? Yeah.
I just said that doesn't look good.
Why are you throwing them under the bus?
It doesn't look like he's even remotely
warmed up. He looks like he's just like,
well here we go. By the way, if
you have a job as a firefighter,
it's one of the best jobs to do other
shit cause you have four days on,
four days off, two days on, four days off,
something like 24 hour shifts and
the um, you know, a fire house of,
it's a good firehouse is a great place to
work. Obviously. It's a very dangerous,
obviously there's a lot of responsibility.
My friend Ray back in New York was a
firefighter. We used to call him ray,
the fireman and he fucking loved it
because he could do all kinds of shit.
While I was at work,
he learned how to be a cook because they
would have times where they didn't have
to do anything. The fireman, you call them
natural creators, it was at a pool hall.
Why Things Charlie? Where's he from?
White plains. You know, I love it.
And Tommy Bell, Tommy's from
Malvern. Martial arts studios.
Have that to my friend Brendan the
fighter. Yeah, there was Deli Steve. Yup.
Cause he worked at the Deli. How
they can't leave the firehouse? No,
when they're on they cannot,
won't go to the store.
Maybe they can go to the store.
They do shifts and shit like that and I'm
sure they have to stay at the station.
You might be right out of the deal.
You can't be driving
around just you get a call,
you got to chill and firehouses to have
such a cool like chief the let's dude.
But he has, I'm on call. It goes dude,
you got to meet us at the fucking,
well I'm sure they covered our basis.
I'm sure they cover their bases.
You know like when a guy is scheduled on,
you know it was probably another guy
that's scheduled to go shopping for them.
You can do push ups all day.
That's the thing.
You can do a lot of training and a lot
of those gyms in firehouses are pretty
stocked up. And they did Jujitsu.
Heavy bag. Steve Bay played baseball.
Play baseball. Yeah. Pro
Hours. He was drafted.
Never played complete baseball
at Cleveland State and
wrestled. Good athlete, man.
Great Athlete. Who Deep
Bass Guy. Oh, he's American.
He's just weird creatures and stuff,
I think. Yeah, Croatian descent.
He would wear the cro cop shorts every
day when we trained. It was weird.
He speaks perfect English. Oh yeah. He
doesn't speak any notion. Yeah. Pick six,
four, two 30. [inaudible].
These are heavy waves.
Six 14 so a little bit bigger than you,
Bro. I don't know about that. I haven't.
I mean just cause I got training right
now because if I do eight issue after
pool sprints, Bro, I hear
that whole spread luck. You
pressing my hands
as long as you,
as long as you don't hit me back.
I can fucking move
about your jab. Jab, Jab,
jab is lightening. It's viper quick.
They call me the viper and the job.
Am I right? Yeah, he has to. He's got to
stop with the heart thing kills me. I'll,
I told Eddie to stop chewing in front
of the thing I'm showing in front of it.
Mows your cards. Password. Brian.
My guard passing is, is a, um,
they call me slick and did you Jujitsu
to circles. That's what I heard honestly.
But I caught myself with oil.
If you were a referee,
would you do a heart or would you call
it with your own mood? What would it be?
I do a Haka dance. Could you do just a
ball crater a ball and hold the shaft?
No movement. No. Instead of this,
know what I was doing.
Do you do that for me? I'm like, this,
could you do that? There's
no way. He was a fighter.
Like if you lost the big batch job,
you remember when?
When I'm a fucking Dennis Hallman
lost that bet and he wore those little
skivvies fired. Then they get
fired, but he got in trouble.
He wore like the shortest old
school valley. Today's top.
That was Marco [inaudible]. He used to,
we used to wear those speedo karate.
They do this thing instead of doing
that one like that with the fist over.
If you just do like this,
it's basically you're saying to the
balls and hold the shaft. There you go.
Oh Dude,
wait.
[inaudible] the difference inside,
but people
don't see that much of a difference.
I do. Oh my God. Optical illusion.
I want to call it out like that.
I wouldn't call it out like that.
Let me see when they're
moving. He's a foot tall. No,
he's so much bigger. Come on.
Fat. Does Fabio look like the owner
of crossfit? A little bit. Little bit.
It's not a big deal though.
I can throw down.
I'm going to go with Fabiano
of Malden. Ira. No. Oh,
snaps hit him right away in the face.
Fox Care from me.
There's not that big of a
difference. The steep. Oh No,
no, no. Five survive.
STP backed off control.
He's going to come back home
because it comes super competent.
Going to put this guy asleep. No,
he's not worried about it at all.
He's so much bigger. Didn't
exactly. He heard him smart.
He's not rushing in and
all that's a veteran move.
That's expanse not rushing in there. Oh
that's what's not fair. He's way too big.
Come on. That's it. He's waiting.
You. Oh boy. Jesus. He's telling me.
Oh check way to hit way too hard.
Nobody ever did that, that fight.
Let's be honest.
What's absolutely be honest.
The only reason why sanctioned
that fights cause it's in Brazil,
they wanted to save the call. Denato
asked for it and it'll save the card.
You're absolutely right. In Malden. I was
such a beast. People like, you know what?
Give him a chance, but
look at this man, boy,
boom,
that right hand.
That's why if it really is an 85
or fighting a elite heavyweight,
that's exactly how it should go down.
Knock you out, Brian. That's honestly,
I would have rode that shot.
He called it an 80 fiver.
He could have been 95 and he wasn't
even really elite at light heavyweight.
It was just tough. Oh, he's just a
guy. This is a dangerous matchup.
It's super dangerous. It makes me sad.
Nobody ever did this to him before,
but you're dealing with a totally
different kind of thump and that's what
Brendan was talking about.
He's talking about the difference between
flyweights and heavyweights. This boom,
damn, that's hidden looking like he
punched him hard either rock hearted.
It looks like he punched him lunch.
How dare you say, right, right.
Agree with [inaudible].
Straight ride on the
jaw from a heavy loud,
from your vantage point. It doesn't
look like a, he like he won't wound up.
He just like a short jab punch.
Isn't the gems perfect.
Punch a short by not giving him
credit. He deserves Brian. Listen guys,
I think Steve Bay's uphill both ways.
I say hi. No route for Brian. Hey Brian,
how come you not giving them credit?
I'm like, I thought about it. I'm like,
I thought maybe you were doing let me how
much automatically, but did he really?
Did you really say that?
But that was,
I'm just saying it was a
deceptive is short. Right?
Of course it's gonna Knock
'em out, but I just, it's not,
it doesn't look like he hit an
Sro haymaker from his hip. Right?
That's what I'm saying Brian.
It was a perfect right hand.
Well you haven't seen my right hand.
I've seen it all.
We want to talk about emotion. I've seen
real kick to see here. What else do paid?
Wildly impressed with that. What would
Joey say to Brian if he was here? Right.
Listen, cock. Cocksucker enough is enough.
And then what the fuck you talking
about? That it, that right hand hit you.
You'd be back in Afghanistan
looking for frogs.
You'll be on the jungle cock sucker.
What your fucking Turpentine
[inaudible] Paul's fuck face.
That's a good Joey Diaz impersonation.
Get back in the fucking jungle
and we've for waters guys, I'm,
I'm discussing it and
fucking right hand hit you.
You wouldn't even know a
million ants walking over you.
You'd be sleeping like a baby
answer attacking you. You'd wake up, it'd
be fucking three days later. Skeleton,
no aunts, no nothing. Even the
answer. Feel sorry for you.
This motherfucking so alcohol. We can't
even eat them. It'd be a travesty.
That's like jungle laws,
like some universal jungle harmony.
Just to respect the answer,
we'll go around you and eat an
elephant. He was right here. Boom. Yeah.
Jesus' bride, the temp. I don't even
understand how he went down
from this fucking perfectly
pleased. Right hand shot,
240 pounds, super
heavyweight, all knuckles.
That's a lot of weight behind that.
Find some God damn telephone
poles striking you in the
face. It's not fun guys.
You made a mistake, Brian? No,
I'm just saying there are
guys who take that car to go.
You just realize you made a mistake.
You'll be waking up in a fucking
tent back up, back up, back up.
Some of the horses run on corn flakes.
Brides just back up.
He must've not written. You know
how long has junior high for anyone?
No broken hands, man. Broken
hands where a motherfucker,
you know when you get them,
that's the other thing you started getting
the more often. I have no shirt on.
Vituro has had, cause he forgot
his and he had to give it to him.
He's ready to fight. He's
mad. You can uh, yeah,
they do things you can,
they do things to protect your
hair plates in their surgeries.
But the bottom line is once
you start breaking your hand,
it's very likely going to break it again.
What did you put the
plate before you break?
It would all depends on how much time
you let it heal before you get back to
training. That gets a
place. Brandon. Um, shit,
we fucking not gonna we didn't
watch the Alaska is one punch.
We didn't watch the, uh, the
full, um, Moose saucy fight.
The Musashi versus a,
we didn't see the cut on your elbow.
Can you imagine that? A right now
there, there's no laws against that.
They should jump on it. Don't wait
for it to break. Jump on that.
She did like a wolverine
thing. Yeah. Why not? Let me,
I'm going to find it here for us.
Find it so we could watch Moose
Aussie and there's no way he goes.
No, unfortunately it's, it's on my,
we'll watch the whole thing
since we have the, uh, the time.
Brian Stann, John and I live in
Brazil. Steve Bay. Me. Oh chick man.
He's a motherfucker dude.
He is a motherfucker.
Kenny Florian and Hunada do that
scene from heat. [inaudible] no,
you have no mat.
Dude.
Hit natto and Kenny Florian and do the
scene from hate where they sit in the
diner. Oh, that's great.
It's fucking incredible.
Really fucking octal doing Robert De Niro.
Oh my God. So there's a lot of
insights. Shit, they got to see that.
Most people wouldn't. And that on Youtube.
Yeah. Oh my God. I'm having a hard time.
He's got his own shop.
He's got his own Internet show that
there's a huge smash called the handout
[inaudible] Andra show that's being
produced by flex point. Oh my God.
You go to Youtube licks point and
not the Laronza do. There's a,
there's a scene where he not though gives
Darth Vader at Jujitsu lesson and he
gives it to after the lesson,
he gives him a stripe on his white belt.
Darth Vader.
For some reason this thing is not
allowing me to fast forward it.
I'm having a hard time figuring out how
fast needs to buffer. Yeah, it must be.
It must be cause loop bar not as fighting.
And he was earlier on that car. Yeah.
Do you wanna Watch his
fight? Yeah. Go for it.
Do you guys want to do that or
you want to get some dinner?
Cause it's almost 10 o'clock.
Starving. Yeah. Let's just watch this.
Musafa goes the decision loop
by net loses sigh. Oh Shit.
I can't believe you just get that shot.
Now I'm trying to eat some
type move. Oh Brian, give me
some air to heritage. Yeah,
it's buffering in southern California.
You want to go to my show tomorrow?
Eddie Bravo.
invitational.com tickets are 25 bucks.
We made it nice and cheap
tomorrow at four 30 and
what time would end if people,
it all depends on how fast the matches go.
It could end in an hour or it could last
time limit. It's just submission. No, no,
no,
no.
It's submission only 10 minute rounds
and we have a submission based overtime
like extra innings like we go over time
I get to get on your back would double
over under with both leg hooks.
What it's like extra.
It's extra innings either if I get
you then you get a chance on my back.
If I escape then I win.
It's like extra anything that's cool.
But if you tap me too,
then we go another extra that's like
overtime college football chance to,
it's exact, we both get a chance to
attack our overtime, you know, 10 minutes,
10 minute rounds and then a three,
three maximum over time innings,
extra innings.
If we go three innings and it's still
tie like maybe the first round both got a
sub second round, both escaped
third round, both escape.
So you could sub each other more than
once in a match. It's like extra innings.
It's like,
so it's supposed to get a chance.
We go into overtime instead of
overtime being based on wrestling.
It's like whoever has the
best wrestling will win.
A lot of wrestlers will stall and,
and,
and want to win in overtime because
they know that wrestling has dominant.
We're trying to eliminate that. So
what is your, uh, how does it work?
Let's say we go 10 minutes and there's
also a mission. Let we go into overtime.
You get to you, it's like extra innings
and baseball you get, you're the,
you're the top half of an ending.
You get my back,
both leg hooks with an over under.
If you submit me now I get a
chance to get you. If you escape,
you win. Cause I couldn't score.
We both had a chance. You scored.
But if you tapped me to, they only go on
other ending. Then you get on my back.
I escape. Then I get on your back,
you escape. We'd go another ending.
So and then the next inning you tap me
and then when I get my shot you escape.
You win. That's interesting.
Basically this idea.
Lots of cannabis, lots of
cans allegedly. Yes. Yes.
We've uh,
we've been doing this at the Midwest
submission challenge in the Midwest and
it's working out great. Uh, you
know, so we're trying it out and
the whole,
the whole format was all designed to
try to make Jujitsu exciting enough.
So networks would want it Eric,
cause we got dog Frisbee,
we got ridiculous sports.
Be An Eric. We have to have,
there was no reason to not
have Jiu Jitsu on TV. Right.
But the only way you're going to do it
is you've got to eliminate the points
system. Cause that'll never work, right?
We've had Jujitsu with a point system
for 20 years. We don't see any TV out.
No one people have looked
at it and they're like, no
way. We can't put this on TV.
So it has to be submission only.
And um, ultimately it's gotta,
it's gotta be about money.
It's gotta be like a game show,
like a 60 man bracket and
the guy who wins it all,
he's the only guy who gets paid
then that'll increase the urgency,
make it submission, only
give some mission, uh, uh,
submission bonuses and incentive.
That way you throw so much money out of
these guys are in there to make as much
money as possible.
Right?
So that translates to entertainment
for the guys watching because you know,
that's really who important
here that the audience,
we want to make it to the audience
can't wait to see this shit.
And the only way that's
going to happen is you have,
you provide you Jitsu matches
that are incurred rattle
bowl. You're like, Oh shit,
yes, there's still going to be some boring
matches. But overall you want like 60,
70% of the matches to be exciting
enough so that your average UFC fan will
enjoy. Because right now most UFC
fans do not want to watch the moon.
Dealz then do not want to
watch ADCC there and the MMA,
they don't want to watch they dip into it.
We,
there are so many people that in the,
that are fans of the UFC that would be
down for grappling and they would down be
down to watch it even though
they didn't do Jujitsu.
If it was exciting enough and that's what
I'm trying to do, I may fail miserably,
but I'm trying, I'm trying to make
Jujitsu as entertaining as possible. Uh,
not to make money just to, just
to make Jujitsu Cooler. That's it.
Okay.
Musashi and looking at Marcos
are fighting right now and uh,
I started at while you were still talking,
so back it up so we could all
get the some marks. Game Plan.
Here's all we worked on was
movement and be unpredictable.
Change your levels and not only
just shoot for, take downs,
but set it up with your big hands.
But you can tell right away.
He kind of just shoots from, that's
way too far to shoot it right there.
Especially on the gallic massage,
getting harder and harder. Look,
he's got ahold of her hard,
he's got 'em up and boom takes him down,
but lands can't control.
That's amazing. Amazing,
Amazing Bass by moon sauce.
So the whole camp,
the biggest thing was level
changes and movement for mark.
Don't get backed up to the cage and come
over the right hand with the well over
a Musashi's Jab.
It's easier said than done when you
have a vicious striker coming at you.
I'm just telling you that that
was the game plan dog does it.
I'm just telling you what the, the, the,
our plan was and then obviously you
see it come to live here, got that.
Have long arms of wrestlers is Munoz,
is he's top level in the UFC.
He's facing a guy who didn't wrestle
in college and he's having a hard time
taking her down.
It's getting hard to take dudes down.
So when you're in a situation like
this in a scenario where you're,
you're Munoz and,
and your,
your sole mission is to take him
down and beat him on the ground.
And if you can't do that,
which
is coming up all the time, he's forced
into a kickboxing match where he's um,
outclassed.
Honestly,
this is why it's hard to take them down
cause Musashi doesn't commit to his
punches. He just don't rush in. He's
always using his linked, you'll see me,
he's jabbing, jabbing, leaning
in the right hand. He never
rushes in at the waist.
He's got a good start.
His basis far back is basis very far back.
Look how low is too low.
He gets to the office and by pulling
back when your low like that,
you give yourself an extra
six inches where that dude
can't punch you. Yup. Smart.
It should be how low he is.
Musashi was really fucking impressive
in the Machida FY two man Witchita
obviously it was more impressive,
but I was,
I was impressed by his ability to
take a shot to Machida head kick.
That was a good shot by mark. That's
a good shy. There's defended it
in the middle of that shot.
He could have pulled half guard
and try to get on top another way.
Cause there's two ways
to get on top for mark.
Either take him down with the classic
wrestling take down that he's so good at
or you'd take the long way to get on top.
You can't take the guy down. He's hard,
he's got good base.
It's way easy to shoot and pull half
guard and you've got to have some high
quality half guard sweeps.
But that's how Nogueira beat Tim silver.
You've got to prepare.
You've got to be super high level that
every fighter should be trying to get
super high level cause
that's how Nogueira beat Tim.
Silvia Nogueira cannot take Tim and
Tim Silvia was winning on his feet.
The weight Nogueira got the fight to the
ground as he shot. He pulled half gone,
wind swept, swept him. They got on
touch and then kill it. So crazy.
Mark doesn't have the time to do that
Jujitsu. You know what I'm saying?
He's too far in his career now to
learn that crazy 600 ad nasty crank.
He would be amazing.
He would be so confident where he could
pull half guard and sweep instead of
coming. It's just not as nature though.
You know what I'm saying? He's got a,
he's got to adapt because
this is going to come.
This guy's not even a wrestler
and he can't take them
down and it's getting hard.
It's getting hard. I want to talk about
these. I want to talk about these elbows.
It's so crazy that you can do a downward
elbow as long as it's on the side.
As long as it's side where it makes
sense. It's totally ridiculous. Stupid.
It's the same exact movement as
a 12 to six. It's just common.
It's going 12 to six like sideways.
Who made that rule?
The athletic look at that and
if our athletic commissioner
that amount, God damn,
that mountain was nice. Yeah. If
Munoz had a thick sick half guard,
it would look a lot different. Look at
it. He got him here. Can happen. Why not?
Why not? He's not as he committed
himself to that I met mark.
Mark is going to fire you. Well why
wouldn't he? I know mark very well.
Mark's don't fight one more time in
the Philippines and then call it quits.
I bet is you've been thinking about
calling it quits anyway. Yeah. Maybe.
Do you want to talk to about, my point
is maybe he retires after this, but uh,
I believe
the out of sick.
How old guard I would his old man,
36.
Is that a lot of flights to in wrestling?
He doesn't have the time to commit to it.
Yeah. Well he does a bunch of it. I'm,
I'm with you man. That'd be dope
as shit. I'm with you. Yeah.
You tried to take him down,
but when you,
you can't take this guy down second
round, third round your, your corner.
She was saying, listen, you can't
take this motherfucker down.
You're going to shoot pool half guard and
sweep this month for longer. Yeah. Yeah.
There's so many sweeps you
could do from half guard. Yeah.
You can get on top of that way.
Yeah. No, Gary has done it.
That many people have done that.
You just don't pay attention completely
out of time. We're four minutes.
This thing's going to shut off. Okay,
let's go. I gotta wrap it up. Uh,
everybody listening.
We'll do this every time we get a chance.
It's fun to show you guys going to come
to my shows. I know. Here's the thing,
Joe can't go. Can you go?
Do you want to go? I can't.
Tomorrow. You can't. Great. Wow.
That's amazing. Now Jamie, do you want to
go to my show tomorrow? Go Daddy. Show me.
Let me make show Jesus Christ you guys
for the support. Do these whenever we can.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we do these whenever we can go.
I'm going to watch a DVD with my
girlfriend. Thank you. Oh my God. Uh,
we do these whenever we can. Um,
but uh, there are a lot of fun.
But here's the thing,
you can't expect us to call the
fights if we're hanging out.
You're just watching the fights with us.
If we want to talk shit, that's fine.
If we want to call the fights,
that's fine too.
But you got to just accept what it is.
You can't try to change the,
I don't even talk about the
fight. Exactly. I've already
got those twitters. Yeah,
go fuck your mother. We're going
to talk about whatever we want.
Stop even look at Cuba. Yeah. I didn't
know he was still articulate. All right.
That's it. We're out of time.
Thank you everybody. Good night.
We'll be back next week with actual real
podcasts that a aren't fight companions,
but again, we'll do this
again. Eddie Bravo would do
the scan with this. Fuck. Yeah,
you kidding? This is one of the
funnest podcast of all time.
I'm not doing it again. I get made fun
of shut up. No, I'll ring you back.
We'll bring you back. Goodnight. Everybody
could see you soon. See you Monday.
Big Kiss.
Okay.